Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum 15. Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Marc Sackop-Ost und ich behandle heute hier ein besonderes Thema. Und deshalb starten wir auch ohne die bekannte Musik einfach nur so.
Es ist einfach so, dass ich kein richtiges Vertrauen auch mehr in meinen Knie habe und ich nicht halbherzig spielen kann. Das kann ich – was heißt halbherzig? aber ich kann keine halben Sachen machen. Und wenn es zur Qual wird und das war es in letzter Zeit, dann muss ich einfach entscheiden und das habe ich getan.
Ein Stück mehr Menschlichkeit, ein Stück mehr Zivilcourage, ein Stück mehr Bekenntnis zur Würde des Menschen, des Nächsten, des Anderen. Das wird Robert Enke gerichtet. Ich bedanke mich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Wo sind Sie hingegangen, wenn Sie das Gefühl hatten, ich muss jetzt mal schwach sein?
Ja, ich habe das leider für mich behalten. Ich habe dann versucht, die Schwachmomente zu überspielen, um für andere stark zu wirken. Und das hat leider auch dazu geführt, dass ich dann quasi so tief abgerutscht bin, wie es dann passiert ist. Im Nachhinein wäre es besser gewesen, sich an vertrauten Menschen zu eröffnen. Vielleicht hätte es dann eine schnellere, bessere Lösung gegeben.
Es ist für jeden erkennbar, dass du einen Fehler gemacht hast. Das weißt du auch als Schiedsrichter. Und der Umgang damit, die Kritik vom Chef. Ich habe Zeiten erlebt, da war das so, dass mir der Chef Rückendeckung gegeben hat. Der hat gesagt, das kriegen wir schon wieder hin. Weil die Frage, dass es ein Fehler war, das wussten wir alle. Das andere in den anderen Zeiten, wo es mir schlecht ging, da war das anders. Da kam nicht, das kriegen wir hin, sondern da wurde mir gesagt, jeder darf einen Fehler machen. Nur du nicht, Babak.
Letztendlich liegen jetzt elf interessante, spannende und auch sehr emotionale Wochen hinter mir. Aber ich kann mit voller Überzeugung sagen, dass ich den Schritt nicht bereue, dass ich auf jeden Fall wieder gesund hier zurückgekommen bin, mich wohlfühle und im Prinzip auch mit den Therapeuten vor Ort in der Klinik alles dafür getan habe, um die stationäre Behandlung abzuschließen und letztendlich wieder hier zu sein in Hannover und mein Training wieder aufzunehmen.
Wir wollen heute über Depressionen im Fußball sprechen und im Intro konntet ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dazu ein paar O-Töne von den bekanntesten Fällen dazu hören. Sebastian Deisler, Robert Enke, Andreas Biermann, Babak Rafati und zuletzt jetzt mit Markus Miller war auch ein Spieler, das nach einer behandelten Depression in den Fußball zurück geschafft hat und heute Torwarttrainer der deutschen U15-Nationalmannschaft ist. Diese Sendung liegt mir sehr am Herzen, möchte ich schon seit dem Start des Rasenfunks vor drei Jahren machen und umso froher bin ich, zwei Gäste zu haben, die mir dabei helfen können, dieser Thematik gerecht zu werden. Deshalb begrüße ich zum einen Dr. Karsten Henkel, Oberarzt an der Uniklinik Aachen und Facharzt für Psychiatrie und Psychotherapie sowie Facharzt für Neurologie. Zudem wirkt er an der sportpsychiatrischen Sprechstunde mit, über die wir im Verlauf der Sendung sicher auch noch sprechen werden. Herr Henkel, herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk und danke für Ihre Zeit. Und zum anderen bin ich froh, Ronald Reng hier bei mir in der Leitung zu haben. Er war Freund von Robert Enke und hat mit seinem Buch zum Tod des Nationalthöters wirklich ein eindrucksvolles Werk hinterlassen, das ich jedem nur sehr ans Herz legen kann. Es ist nicht sein einzig gutes Buch. Und neben dem Schreiben engagiert er sich auch im Kuratorium der Robert-Enke-Stiftung. Hallo Herr Reng. Ja, wir haben heute ein nicht ganz so leichtes Thema auf dem Tapet, aber ein umso wichtigeres Thema. Und mir war es auch wichtig, das Ganze nicht anders gebunden zu besprechen, also nicht an einem Todestag oder wenn dann vielleicht doch wieder ein aktueller Fall an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt, denn das ist vielleicht so eins der Probleme der ganzen Debatte um dieses, wie es viele nennen, Tabuthema im Fußball. Jetzt ist es ja aber nicht nur auf den Fußball beschränkt, die Depression. Deswegen würde ich gerne ganz vorne anfangen, Herr Dr. Henkel. Was ist denn eine Depression?
Ja, eine Depression ist erstmal eine Krankheit. Also wir hatten ja eben schon in den Einspielungen gehört, dass etwas wie Schwäche oder Missstimmung teilweise adressiert wurden. Aber nein, eine Depression ist eine Krankheit. Es ist eine auch psychische, aber auch körperliche Erkrankung, die vor allen Dingen mit Kardinalsymptomen wie einer schlechten Stimmung, einer Freudlosigkeit, vermehrten Ermütbarkeit, Erschöpfung einhergeht. Und zu solchen Kardinalsymptomen kommen dann manchmal auch noch weitere Symptome dazu, wie Gewichtsverlust, wie Appetitlosigkeit, aber auch sowas wie Schmerzen und körperliche Symptome, Erschöpfung, die dann sich auch wirklich anfühlen, wie auch eine körperliche Erkrankung.
Ist das für Mediziner wie sie eine klar zu fassende Krankheit, oder ist das vielleicht schon eine der Schwierigkeiten, wenn wir über Depressionen sprechen? Ich würde jetzt sagen, Stimmungsschwankungen hat jeder mal. Das ist nicht immer gleich eine Depression, es kann aber mit ein Anzeichen dafür sein. Gibt es denn so klare Faktoren, wo man sagen kann, das muss gegeben sein? Dann haben wir es mit einer Depression zu tun.
Stimmungsschwankungen haben wir alle. Ein bisschen schlechte Stimmung oder eine Trauerreaktion, wenn ein nahe Verwandter verstorben ist oder man selber an einer schweren Krankheit leidet. Auch das ist im Spektrum des Normalen noch nicht gleich eine Krankheit. Aber wenn sich die Symptomkonstellation so äußert, dass sich verschiedene Symptome addieren, wenn es zu schweren Auswirkungen des allgemeinen Vitalgefühls und auch körperlichen Veränderungen kommt, dann ist natürlich zweifelsohne eine Krankheit vorliegend. Zum Beispiel kann es dazu führen, dass es auch zu Änderungen im Hormonhaushalt kommt, dass plötzlich bei Frauen die Regelblutung ausbleibt, dass gewichtsveränderungen da sind. Das ist etwas, wo man sich klar wird, dass es schon längst an einem Krankheitsstadium erreicht ist. Wir können da nicht mehr von Befindlichkeitsstörungen sprechen.
Ich glaube, im Anfangsstadium ist eine Depression tatsächlich oft für Laien oder auch für Nichtfachärzte, für Allgemeinärzte nicht so leicht zu fassen, weil sie eben auch sehr viel mit körperlichen Symptomen einhergeht. Also absolute Müdigkeit, Antriebslosigkeit. Aber wenn wir dann von einer wirklich tiefen oder schweren Depression reden, die den Menschen massiv einstrengt, dann kann ein Arzt und auch ein Laie, der sich ein bisschen damit befasst hat, sehr wohl eine Depression erkennen oder vermuten. Also Sportler zum Beispiel, wir reden ja hier über Fußballer, die ich kenne, die ich kannte, Robert Enke, Martin Amedick, Kapitän vom 1. FC Kaiserslautern, der eine Depression hatte. Wenn ich ihnen so ein bisschen erzähle, was die hatten, dann wird ihnen sehr schnell klar, dass das nicht eine Schwäche ist oder auch nicht mit unserem normalen, tagtäglichen Begriff von da war ich mal depressiv einhergeht. Also das geht so weit tatsächlich, dass Martin Amedick, Kapitän des 1. FC Kaiserslautern, wollte sich fürs Auswärtsspiel vorbereiten und war nicht mehr in der Lage, seine Tasche zu packen, weil er es einfach nicht mehr geschafft hat, sowohl körperlich als auch diese. Das war ihm schon zu viel, eine geistige Anstrengung. Robert Enke saß in der Kabine, er war Kapitän von Hannover 96. Die Jungs waren es gewohnt, dass er Späße macht, dass er irgendwelche Komiker nachmacht und dass er als Kapitän klar seine Meinung sagt. Der hat in der Kabine einfach nicht mehr gesprochen plötzlich. Das sind sehr greifbare Symptome oder Veränderungen an einem Menschen, die mit einer schweren Depression einhergehen. Deswegen kann man sie, glaube ich, schon im schweren Stadium sehr gut abgrenzen gegenüber den alltäglichen, in Anführungszeichen, normalen Stimmungsschwankungen, den Menschen unterliegen.
Herr Ost, Sie haben aber was Wichtiges gesagt, nämlich, dass es am Anfangsstadium durchaus Symptome gibt, die noch nicht ganz klar zu unterscheiden sind. Personen selber merken manchmal noch gar nicht, dass sie sich mal eine Krankheit anbahnen, sondern sehen das als Reaktion auf eine vermehrte Belastung oder wenig Schlaf. Das ist manchmal bei bestimmten Personen, die versuchen, durchzuhalten und alles mit sich selbst abzumachen, schwierig, bei bestimmten Symptomen Hilfe zu suchen. Ein sehr frühes Zeichen bei Depressionen ist ganz häufig Schlafstörungen. Insbesondere Durchschlafstörungen, Frühjahrwachen morgens, Frühjahrwachengrübelneigung. Manchmal registriert man gar nicht, dass das schon nicht mehr ganz gesund ist und ein Zeichen sein kann, wenn andere Symptome dazukommen, zum Beispiel eine Beginnendepression. Was Herr Reng eben gesagt hat, ist auch ganz relevant. Die körperlichen Symptome können gerade bei Sportlangen ganz im Vordergrund stehen und beeinträchtigen ja auch am meisten, wenn man plötzlich Muskelschmerzen hat, wenn man Kopfschmerzen hat, wie gesagt, die Schlafstörungen zu allgemeiner Müdigkeit führen. Dann sind das Symptome, die einerseits sehr beeinträchtigend sind, andererseits aber auch gekannt werden. Also ein Sportler, der sich in einer Trainingssituation befindet und ein aufbau an Fitness und Performance versucht, der macht ja ein bisschen mehr und gibt einen Trainingsreiz. Das führt zu einem Symptom wie Müdigkeit danach oder Muskelkater. Ein Sportler kennt das deswegen auch. Ein Sportler weiß, ich muss ja ein bisschen Gas geben sozusagen und meinen Körper fordern, um auch eine Leistungssteigerung zu bekommen. Das kann natürlich sein, dass wenn diese Symptome, wenn es sich sehr stark ausprägt, über Trainingssyndromen bezeichnet werden, dann diese Symptome sind sehr ähnlich, die einer Depression. Da kann es dann manchmal verzögert erst ins Bewusstsein geraten, dass es etwas ist, was nicht dem alltäglichen, sportlichen Trainingsalltag entspricht, sondern sich vielleicht darüber hinaus aufbaut und eine Schnittmenge haben kann, zum Beispiel unter Depression.
Herr Reng, Sie haben in Ihrem Buch geschrieben, für Robert Enke waren seine depressiven Phasen wie hinter Doppelglas. Sie sprechen auch einmal vom schwarzen Blick. Welches Gefühl wollen Sie denn damit beschreiben? Denn das ist so meiner Meinung nach eines der Probleme, wenn man über Depressionen spricht, dass es fast unmöglich ist, sich vorzustellen, wie es im Kopf eines depressiv Erkrankten aussieht.
Also das vorherrschende Gefühl eines depressiv Erkrankten ist offenbar das Gefühl der absoluten Gefühlslosigkeit. Das kommt immer wieder mit zwei depressiven Leuten. Ich fühle mich nicht mehr, ich spüre nicht mehr. Bei Robert zum Beispiel ganz plastisch, er hat ja versucht, bei seiner zweiten schweren Depression 2009, die dann auch tödlich endete, hat er versucht weiter zu trainieren. Und nach dem Training, in dem Training, wo er offenbar drei Weltklasseparaden hingelegt hat, hat er dann beim Auslaufen zu seinem Mitspieler Hanno Balic gesagt, Hanno, ich kann morgen nicht spielen. Warum kannst du morgen nicht spielen, Robbie? Ich spüre meine Beine nicht mehr, ich spüre nichts mehr. Also dieses Gefühl, nicht mehr über seinen Körper zu herrschen. Das ist natürlich gerade für Sportler ein schreckliches Gefühl. Das ist ein vorherrschendes Gefühl. Und im Kopf ist es offenbar diese wirklich endlose, spirale, negative Gedanken. Bei Robert fing das an morgens, dass er nicht aufstehen wollte. Er wollte einfach nicht aus dem Bett, weil die Erwartungen des Tages – und das waren so alltägliche Erwartungen wie, ich muss um neun Uhr beim Training erscheinen – da erwarten alle von mir, dass ich normal bin. Das hat ihn schon so gelähmt und solche Angst eingejagt, dass er gar nicht aufstehen wollte. Und da diese negative Denkspirale, die da in Gang gesetzt wurde, zieht es sich beim Deposiven dann offenbar 24 Stunden, noch sehr oft durch den Tag. Bei Robert war es so, er kam aus dem Bett raus unten, hat die Garderobe gesehen und da hingen dann fünf Jacken statt, wie üblich drei, und dann fing er an, wie sieht denn diese Garderobe schon wieder aus? Also wirklich an jedem kleinsten Detail, das er erblickt hat, hat er das Negative gesehen. Und das ist natürlich, kann man sich vorstellen, für denjenigen unglaublich anstrengend, dieses Gefühl unendlich selber, dieses Gefühl unendlich in eine Schleife zu stecken. Und man sieht nichts mehr Positives. Wofür es auch wieder, das ist ja, glaube ich, das war ja auch ihr Anliegen im Anfang, das zu erklären. Das ist keine Schwäche, wo man dann sagen kann, demjenigen, jetzt reiß dich mal zusammen, die Sonne scheint doch und es hängen da noch vier Jacken an der Garderobe. Da sind chemische Veränderungen im Gehirn, finden da statt. Zum Beispiel die Neurotransmitter, die dem Gehirn, also unsere menschlichen Erregungen zuführen, auf Freude, Erregung dem Gehirn melden, die funktionieren nicht mehr zum Großteil. Die sind zum Großteil ausgeschaltet. Deswegen ist es also eine Krankheit, gegen die sich der Einzige mit gutem Willen alleine gewiss nicht mehr wehren kann.
Ich habe gelesen, Herr Dr. Henkel, im Zuge meiner Recherche, dass die Redewendungen alles grau in grau sehen, wohl auch einen zumindest Bezug zur Krankheit. Depressionen hätte, weil es wohl Fälle gibt, in denen sogar die Farbwahrnehmung bei Depressiven sich verändert, eben hin zu mehr grau banal gesprochen. Können Sie mal kurz erklären, was sind denn das für chemische Prozesse, die da greifen?
Wir wissen, dass ja unser Denkenfühlen an die ganzen Prozesse im Gehirn ja, wie Herr Renger schon gesagt hat, durch neurochemische Prozesse ablaufen. Und die Transmitter sind in ein Ungleichgewicht geraten, die Überträgerstoffe, und führen letztlich dazu, dass die Funktion deutlich beeinträchtigt ist. Und das Ganze ist natürlich komplex. Also hängt auch so ein bisschen davon den Kompensationsmechanismen des Gehirns ab, von der Prädisposition, also auch genetisch veranlagt. Die genug Reserve an diesen Transmitterstoffen da ist. Oder ob man eher sozusagen schon von vornherein einen gewissen Mangelzustand oder einen Restzustand hat. Das heißt also, jeder hat so den genetischen Erbanlagen eine Grundschwelle mitbekommen, mit der er sich wehren kann. Und dann, wenn bestimmte Belastungsfaktoren zusammenkommen, dann führt es bei einem früher und beim anderen später dazu, dass diese Schwelle zur Depression überschritten wird und dann möglicherweise sich entsprechend klinisch auswirkt. Aber so dieses Gefühl oder was beschrieben wird, alles durch eine graue Brille sehen, das ist in der Tat vielleicht auch im übertragenen Sinne gemeint, aber auch andere Wahrnehmungen, wie zum Beispiel Schmerzen. Die Schmerzwahrnehmung wird verändert, das heißt die Schmerzschwelle ändert sich häufig. Das sind doch dieselben Überträgerstoffe übrigens, die auch unterdrücken von Schmerzen, die auch notwendig sind für die Unterdrückung von schlechter Stimmung.
Ich denke, eine Veränderung im Körper, die dem Leiden ganz gut erklärt, und wie groß das Leiden eines Depressiven ist, ist die Veränderung des Cortisol-Spiegels. Das Cortisol ist unser Stresshormon und das brauchen wir ja auch. Wir müssen ja manchmal in Anspannung sein, gerade beim Sport, wir müssen bereit sein. Aber bei einem Depressiven ist der Cortisol-Spiegel konstant deutlich höher als in einem nicht kranken Zustand. Vielleicht kann man es sich ganz gut als Hörer vorstellen, wenn man sich jetzt selber mal in eine Stresssituation versetzt. Wenn man Sportler ist, sagen wir mal, die Situation direkt vor dem Anpfiff, wie angespannt man da ist oder als Student vielleicht die drei Minuten vor der Prüfung. Und wenn man sich dann vorstellt, in dem Zustand, in dem man sich in diesem Moment befindet, befindet sich ein Depressiver über konstant den ganzen Tag hindurch, dann weiß man, wie anstrengend das ist und wie schmerzhaft das ist, um unter dieser Krankheit zu leiden.
Völlig richtig, was Herr Reng sagt. Und das Cortisol, das kann dann auch toxische Effekte haben. Das ist ein Stresshormon, was wir eigentlich auch brauchen, um bestimmte Anspannungssituationen herzustellen, wenn wir uns wehren wollen, fliehen oder so. Das kann natürlich in einer Daueraktivierung sehr störend sein. Und dass man keinen Schlaf mehr findet und so weiter. Und das kann aber auch Auswirkungen auf das Gehirn haben. Und es gibt so einige Areale im Gehirn, von denen man weiß, dass sie sogar ihre Struktur oder ihre Größe ändern können. Und solche Dinge wie z.B. Cortisol oder andere Stressfaktoren können dazu führen, dass sich z.B. bestimmte Areale verkleinern. Wir reden z.B. vom Hippocampus, also einer Region, wo auch Gedächtnisfunktionen z.B. lokalisiert sind.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, jetzt haben wir auch schon ganz gut beschrieben, warum dann so oft eine Depression auch in ein Suizid mündet. Weil wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, ich müsste die ganze Zeit in dem Zustand sein, in dem ich war, fünf Minuten bevor wir diese Sendung gestartet haben.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass du dich dann töten würdest.
Nein, nein, aber das, was einer Prüfungssituation klarkommt.
Aber das ist ja auch was, was viele Leute in der Tat nicht verstehen. Wie kann man sich umbringen, weil sie da wieder ihr normales, gesundes Gehirn voraussetzen. Und Robert Enke im nicht kranken Zustand hätte sich auch nie selbst getötet. Also man ist offenbar dann vier und in so einem Zustand der schwersten Depression gehören Selbstmordgedanken zu den Symptomen dazu. Weil der der Kranke von dieser Krankheit so geplagt wird, dass er nichts anderes mehr denkt, als ich möchte diese Krankheit endlich loswerden. Das ist ein verzweifelter Gedanke. Und Herr Dr. Henkel hat es sehr gut beschrieben, gerade welche chemischen Veränderungen im Gehirn stattfinden. Das heißt, der Kranke leitet unter einer verzerrten Wahrnehmung. Der hat keine gesunde Wahrnehmung mehr. Und in dieser verzerrten Wahrnehmung kommt er auf den wahnsinnigen Gedanken, es gibt nur eine Möglichkeit, diese Krankheit loszuwerden. Und das ist, wenn ich mich umbringe, dann bin ich sie endlich los. Aber ich glaube, wir müssen da auch festhalten, der Selbstmord ist das schlimmste Symptom einer Depression. Und mehr oder weniger die Zahlen gehen von 10.000 Selbsttötungen, Suizide in Deutschland jedes Jahr aus, wobei der größte Anteil der Depression geschuldet ist. Aber wir müssen schon auch festhalten, wir gehen davon aus, dass von den 80 Millionen Deutschen 10 Millionen irgendwann in ihrem Leben mehr oder weniger an Depressionen erkranken. Und davon ist es also nur ein ganz, ganz kleiner Bruchteil, der tatsächlich dann im Suizid endet. Also die meisten Depressionen sind heilbar, werden geheilt. Ich glaube sogar – Herr Dr. Henkel wird das besser wissen – ich glaube sogar die häufigste Depression ist tatsächlich die, die bei einem nur einmal im Leben auftritt. Das heißt, man hat das über einen bestimmten Abschnitt im Jahr und im Leben und dann ist man nie mehr wieder erkrankt. Also das ist die extremste Form, die extremste Symptom der Krankheit, das wirklich aber nur bei einem kleinen Prozentsatz vorkommt.
Also man geht davon aus, dass bis zu 20 Prozent der Bevölkerung in Mitteleuropa einmal im Leben eine depressive Episode erleiden. Und zum Glück sind es häufig oder meistens nicht wieder häufiger Abfolge wiederkehrende depressive Episoden, sondern häufig bleibt es auch bei einer oder zweien. Und auch was sie sagen mit diesen Stressfaktoren und der Flucht aus dieser Situation, die man nicht aushalten kann, dazu kommt halt auch noch mal diese Fehlwahrnehmung, dass man auch die Zukunftsperspektive nicht mehr sieht und dass sozusagen keine Hoffnung mehr in den Gedanken besteht, aus dieser Situation jemals wieder rauszukommen. Also wenn die Personen klar würden, dass das eine vorübergehende Phase ist, die dann aber wieder weggeht, dann werden glaube ich weniger Suizide zu verzeichnen. Aber wenn die Person davon ausgeht, dass es immer so bleiben wird und keine Hoffnung bestünde, dann ist natürlich eine recht hohe Gefahr da, dass dann auch ein Suizid als Ausweg gesehen werden kann. Und deswegen ist das Allerwichtigste, dass wir unseren Patienten immer sagen, das, was sie haben, ist behandelbar und es ist ganz gut behandelbar. Das Nachteil ist, es dauert ein bisschen Zeit und wir müssen gemeinsam schauen, wie wir diese Zeit überbrücken, dass sie es gut aushalten.
Das ist auch eine der Erfolgsgeschichten in der Behandlung der Depression. Wenn wir vergleichen, die Todeszahlen vor 30 Jahren und die Todeszahlen auch heute, die sind deutlich gesunken, weil eben die Krankheit, auch wenn immer noch viele von einem Tabu reden, die Krankheit doch selbstverständlicher geworden ist bei vielen Leuten. Das heißt, das Wissen darüber, die Selbstverständlichkeit, es gehört zum Leben dazu, wie auch physische Krankheiten, wie eine Grippe dazu gehört, wie ein Beinbruch dazugehören kann. Deswegen suchen offenbar auch mehr Leute heutzutage schneller eine Behandlung auf und die Todeszahlen sind in den letzten 30 Jahren deutlich gesunken.
Was man ja vermehrt auch, ich denke, auch in seiner eigenen Umgebung wahrnimmt, in Deutschland ist ein vermehrtes Aufkommen des sogenannten Burnouts oder Erschöpfungssyndrome. Da hatten wir auch ein paar Fälle im Fußball. Herr Dr. Henkel, kann man da eigentlich eine Grenze ziehen zwischen der Diagnose Burnout und der Diagnose Depression oder ist das eine nur ein anderes Wort fürs andere?
Die Zustände sind sicherlich fließend ineinander übergehend. Burnout selber beschreibt ja keine Diagnose im medizinischen Sinne, sondern beschreibt ja häufig, dass man sehr viel investiert hat und sich vielleicht auch überlastet hat. Und die Folge ist sozusagen eine Schöpfungssyndrom. Das kann ein normaler Zustand sein, das kann wirklich eine eigene Überforderung sein. Es kann aber auch Zustände beschreiben, die einer Depression entsprechen. Also insofern gibt es da Überlappungen, aber es ist nicht notwendig, dass vorher sozusagen eine besondere Leistung gewesen sein muss, um eine Depression zu kriegen. Das ist also sicherlich ein Zustand, der dazu führen kann. Aber es gibt natürlich viele andere Ursachen. Wir gehen davon aus, dass es eine multifaktorielle Genese hat. Das heißt, es gibt verschiedene Faktoren, die zusammenkommen. Überlastung und verminderte Ruhephasen können einer von vielen Gründen sein.
Aber eben auch so Dinge wie vorhin schon angesprochen. Vererbung ist zum Beispiel auch möglich. Wir haben schon jetzt ein paar Zahlen genannt. Jeder Fünfte erkrankt statistisch gesehen. Einmal hat es eine depressive Episode. Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO geht davon aus, dass die Depression bis zum Jahr 2020 auf Platz 2 der Volkskrankheiten weltweit vorrücken wird. Derzeit soll die Zahl ungefähr 350 Millionen Erkrankte betragen. Herr Reng, Ihrer Einschätzung nach, kann man diese Zahlen auch auf den Fußball übertragen?
Es gibt keinen Grund, warum der Fußball in irgendeiner Art weniger oder mehr betroffen sein sollte von psychischen und seelischen Krankheiten als jeder andere Beruf. Statistisch kann eine Depression einen in jedem Lebensalter treffen. Es gibt Depressionen bei Kindern, es gibt sie bei Jugendlichen und es gibt sie sehr oft auch bei alten Menschen. Es muss einen Auslöser geben, das ist zumindest die Vermutung der Forschung heutzutage. Vielleicht eine erbliche Anlage und dieser Auslöser, der kann sehr klein sein oder sehr groß sein, der eine Depression auslöst. Zu glauben, es gibt im Fußball, das sind alles sehr stressgestellte Menschen, weil die haben schon sehr viel erlebt im Stressmomente, bis sie zum Profifußball kommen. Deswegen seien sie weniger anfällig, das ist eine Milchmädchenrechnung.
Was kann man denn jetzt konkret gegen eine Depression tun, Herr Dr. Henkel? Wir haben ja schon besprochen, ganz weite Teile der Depression sind heilbar.
Das Allerwichtigste ist erstmal, dass eine Depression erkannt wird. Und dass sie möglichst früh genug erkannt wird, das macht natürlich die Behandlung einfacher. Die muss dann vielleicht nicht stationär erfolgen, sondern kann ambulant erfolgen. Sie muss dann manchmal sogar gut vor Ort erfolgen. Man braucht vielleicht auch in einer ganz frühen Phase, geht sogar schon vom Hausarzt zu betreuen und in schweren Phasen oder Situationen natürlich dann auch vom Facharzt. Aber die Behandlung hängt so ein bisschen von der Schwere der Depression ab. Also man soll wissen, dass wir in leichten Phasen oder im Beginn der mittelschweren Phasen eine Psychotherapie vor allen Dingen notwendig ist und sinnvoll ist, ab mittelschwerer und auch bei schweren Depressionen, aber sollte auch eine Pharmakotherapie, es heißt Medikamente, erwogen werden. Und da gibt es eine ganz große Auswahl, die gut wirksame Medikamente. Und heutzutage haben wir auch viele Medikamente, die auch wenig Nebenwirkungen machen oder gut überschaubare und kontrollierbare Nebenwirkungen. Und eine ganz große Hürde oder Angst ist immer so der Gedanke, entweder ich werde abhängig von den Medikamenten und kann dann nicht mehr ohne danach. Oder aber sie verändern mein Wesen und ich bin ein anderer Mensch und denke ganz anders und habe auch davor Angst. Und beides ist nicht so. Und die Medikamente, die wir geben, wir achten sehr darauf, dass kein Mensch nicht abhängig davon wird. Und es kann mal vorübergehend nötig sein, dass so angstlösende Medikamente auch zum Einsatz kommen. Das tun wir aber meistens nun in den ersten zwei, drei Wochen um, sagen wir mal, den Antidepressiva, die leider ein paar Tage, zehn, 14 Tage brauchen, bis sie wirken und am Anfang vielleicht auch Nebenwirkungen machen, dass man das sozusagen abfängt. Und dann aber danach werden diese Medikamente abgesetzt und die Antidepressiva alleine weitergegeben. Und die haben dann kein Abhängigkeitspotenzial und verändern auch nicht das Wesen eines Menschen.
Und müsste man als Sportler Angst haben, dass man mit diesen Medikamenten etwas einnimmt, was vielleicht auf Dopinglisten steht?
Es ist gut, dass man sich darüber Gedanken macht und dass man sich darum kümmert, natürlich wichtig. Aber die allermeisten Antidepressiva stehen nicht auf der Dopingliste und sind unproblematisch. Da gibt es ja auch entsprechende Medikamentenlisten, die von der NADA oder VADA rausgegeben werden, also der Nationalen oder der Weltantidoping Agentur. Und die meisten von den Medikamenten sind völlig unproblematisch, was das betrifft.
Jetzt haben Sie aber auch schon angedeutet, Antidepressiva brauchen einen gewissen Anlauf. Sie haben, glaube ich, 4 bis 10 Tage gesagt, bis die Medikamente wirken. Das deutet für mich auch darauf hin, dass das jetzt nichts ist, was eine schnelle Therapie ist. Das heißt, anders als bei einem Muskelfaseriss, den ich in vielleicht Profisportler kriegen, das ist ja schon in zwei Wochen teilweise hin, dass sie dann wieder spielen können. Kann man eine Angabe darüber machen, wie lange eine Therapie bei Depressionen andauert, so schwierig es jetzt auch ist, alle Depressionen über einen Kamm zu scheren?
Sie haben natürlich recht. Man kann das sehr individuell verschieden. Und bei manchen Personen reicht es ja auch schon, wenn man sie so ein bisschen aus dem Alltag rausnimmt und sich erholen lässt. Übrigens, eine Depression als depressive Episode bezeichnen wir erst, wenn ein Zustand mindestens zwei Wochen besteht. Aber die Medikation, wie gesagt, hilft ja relativ schnell. Also in zehn bis 14 Tagen beginnt die Wirkung von diesen Antidepressiva. Manche, wenn sie eher den Schlaf schon verbessern, wirken als diese Nebenwirkung schlaffördernd ja auch schon sofort. Und das kann ja auch schon mal zur Erholung mit beitragen, wenn man seinen Schlaf wiederbekommt. Und ja, also ein bisschen Zeit braucht das Ganze natürlich schon. Die Depression kommt ja auch nicht von einem auf den anderen Tag. Und diese Umstrukturierung und Baumechanismen im Gehirn, die brauchen halt ein paar Tage. Aber wie gesagt, es gibt manchmal so zu Überbrückung, manchmal angstlösende Medikamente, braucht man aber häufig auch gar nicht. Und begleitet das Ganze natürlich auch durch Psychotherapien. Und ich glaube, das ist ganz wichtig, wenn wir versuchen, so viel wie möglich an Psychotherapie zur Verfügung zu stellen, ist das natürlich relativ intensiv an Personal. Und bei der hohen Anzahl von depressiv Erkrankten können Sie sich vorstellen, es gibt natürlich da immer wieder ein Loch in der Versorgung. Und wir müssen gucken, wie wir mit unseren Ressourcen da klarkommen.
Ich glaube, für den betroffenen Sportler ist es durchaus vergleichbar, die Heilzeit mit physischen Krankheiten, also Verletzungen. Jetzt eine Bänderverletzung, das kann sein, dass der Sportler damit, der Fußballer zum Beispiel, das einfach nur taped am Sprung gelenkt und damit weiterspielt. So ist es bei einer depressiven Verstimmung durchaus auch möglich, dass der therapiert wird und weiterspielt. Und es gibt aber natürlich schlimmere Depressionen, so wie es auch schlimmere Bänderverletzungen gibt, bis hin zum Kreuzbandriss, bei dem man dann auch sechs Monate ausfällt. Und so ist es auch bei der Depression. Das ist schwierig zu generalisieren und liegt einfach an der Einschätzung des Therapeuten. Wir haben auch Sportler, Konstantin Braun von den Eishockey-Nationalspielern, von den Eisbären Berlin, der hat mit einer erkannten Depression, die er selber hatte, die hat er auch behandeln lassen und hat aber noch die Saison zu Ende gespielt, ist noch deutscher Meister geworden mit den Eisbären Berlin und ist dann in die Therapie gegangen. Also da war noch ein Moment der Kontrolle vorhanden, so wie ich ja manche Fußballer auch mache, mit Bänderverletzung. Die wissen eigentlich, dürfte ich damit nicht mehr spielen. Ich will das jetzt nicht hier jedem empfehlen. Das liegt dann immer in der Einschätzung der Therapeuten. Aber auch das ist bei Depressionen möglich. Also die Depression ist nicht gleich das größte schwarze Schwert, das über einem Sportler schwebt.
Und der Sport selber ist natürlich auch eine Art Therapie, auch für den Sportler. Leute, die gewohnt sind, sich viel zu bewegen, die haben natürlich gerade in Phasen, wo z.B. auch eine Körperlehrverletzung da ist, ein besonderes Risiko, eine Risikosituation, auch mal eher eine Depression zu erhalten oder zu entwickeln, die dann sozusagen die sportliche oder körperliche Verletzung begleitet, weil einfach sozusagen der Sport einen Ausgleich für die meisten Sportler darstellt. Viele leiden dann gerade ganz besonders darunter, sich nicht bewegen zu können oder den Sport nicht nutzen zu können als positives Erlebnis.
Das ist in Anführungszeichen ein Vorteil einer psychischen Krankheit gegenüber einer physischen Krankheit ist, dass man in der Tat den Sport in den meisten Fällen auf kleiner Basis noch weiter machen kann. Also Martin Amedick, der sich dann auch, als er bei Eintracht Frankfurt gespielt hat, aus dem Profibetrieb rausgegangen ist, um sich behandeln zu lassen. Die Behandlung dauerte auch ungefähr vier, fünf Monate. Und er kam von dieser Behandlung zurück und war körperlich fitter denn je, weil er die Zeit einfach genügt hat für ein tiefes Athletiktraining. Auch da muss natürlich dann immer der Therapeut schauen, wie viel Sport mutig dem zu. Aber grundsätzlich ist ja auch die Depressionsforschung heute so weit, dass sie sagt, Dauerlauf zum Beispiel gehört zu einer Therapie dazu, weil es dem Körper hilft, wieder Veränderungen im Körper durchzuführen, um die Depression loszuwerden.
Ja, Sport und Bewegung in der Tat ist ein integraler Bestandteil der Therapie, die wir unseren Patienten, auch die keine Sportler sind, in der Tat anbieten.
Ist es dann nicht vielleicht schon ein Grundproblem, dass wir über solche Geschichten wie Martin Amedick oder Markus Miller – wer auch ein zweites Beispiel, habe ich vorhin schon angesprochen – viel weniger sprechen als über einen Fall wie Robert Enke, Herr Reng?
Naja, das liegt in der Natur des Menschen und der Medien, dass man immer das Außergewöhnlichste herausstellt, weil das als Berichtenswertes erscheint. Ich habe mich das in der Tat auch oft schon gefragt. Verzehren wir als Medien nicht dadurch die Wirklichkeit, indem wir immer nur das Außergewöhnliche berichten und das Außergewöhnliche vielleicht nur einen ganz kleinen Prozentsatz der Wirklichkeit widerspiegelt. Es ist aber nun mal so, dass die Menschen die Normalität offenbar weniger interessiert. Man kann auch nicht von jedem Sportler erwarten, der eine Depression überstanden hat, dass er jetzt in die Öffentlichkeit tritt und darüber redet. Wie der Messias, das kommt vielleicht noch hinzu, dass viele einfach das Gefühl haben, das ist eine intime Krankheit, weil sie betrifft eigentlich unser Innerstes, unseren Kopf. Sie haben das Gefühl, sie kommen damit besser zurecht, mit der Gesundung, mit der Heilung, mit gesund zu leben, wenn sie sich zurückhalten. Ich glaube aber, dass es tatsächlich bei vielen Leuten einfach das Interesse noch sehr oberflächlich ist an psychischen Krankheiten, weil es etwas ist, damit will man am besten nicht in Berührung treten. Davon will man am besten nichts wissen. Das ist so die Vogelstrauß-Politik des Menschen, in den Kopf in den Sand stecken und dann sehen wir das nicht. Aber wer sich damit beschäftigt, bei mir war es zwangsläufig, weil ich eben mit Robert einen Freund verloren habe an die Krankheit, der findet in der Tat, wie sie richtig sagen, sehr viele Beispiele oder die meisten Beispiele von Sportlern, die die Depression überstanden haben, die zurückgekehrt sind in ihr Leben. Ich muss sagen, Markus Miller und Martin Amedick sind dabei zwei gute Beispiele, die bewusster in ihr Leben zurückgekehrt sind, die sich bewusster gefragt haben, wie will ich leben, was will ich machen, was muss ich machen, um gesund zu bleiben. Das sind Kleinigkeiten, wie Markus Miller, der für sich erkannt hat, ich habe eigentlich nur den Fußball im Leben, ich möchte und sollte auch was anderes machen. Der sich gesagt hat, ja, es ist zwar banal, aber ich wollte schon immer Motorrad fahren. Man hat mich das nie getraut, weil ich immer nur dachte, ich könnte mich dabei verletzen und meine Fußballkarriere ist zu Ende. Der das Motorradfahren angefangen hat, das gibt ihm eine größere Lebensfreude. Martin Amedick, der sehr bewusst entschieden hat, er möchte Psychologie studieren, er möchte auch seine Erfahrung, seine Krankheit nutzen, weil er das Gefühl hat, das ist ein Erfahrungsschatz, auch den er hat, und mit Sportlern zusammenarbeiten, mal als Sportpsychologe. Das habe ich eigentlich öfters auch von Sportlern, die eben nicht in die Öffentlichkeit gegangen sind, die nach der Krankheit ein höheres Bewusstsein und dadurch teilweise auch eine höhere Lebensfreude hatten.
Wir neigen ja auch durch solche mediale Aufmerksamkeit für dieses Schicksal zum Beispiel von Robert Enke zu so einer Übergeneralisierung. Wir suchen jetzt im System, in der Gesellschaft, im Fußball selber Schuldige, die sozusagen es geschehen lassen konnten, dass jemand eine Depression kriegt. Aber wir sollten die Sache wirklich auch so benennen, was es ist. Es ist nicht eine Folge von Geldgier oder eine Folge von Geldungssucht oder Ähnliches, sondern es ist halt einer Person passiert, die in diesem System zwar sich auch aufhält, aber die nicht durch das System oder durch den Fußball oder durch den Sport die Depression entwickelt hat. Sondern die Depression wäre ihm auch passiert, wenn er Maurer gewesen wäre oder Casira bei Aldi. Also wichtig ist einfach eine ganz andere Sache. Leute im Sport oder Leute, die auch in der Offenöffentlichkeit stehen, sind natürlich genauso empfänglich wie andere Personen auch. Und das bedeutet andererseits, sie sollten natürlich auch die gleichen Möglichkeiten haben, sich therapieren zu lassen. Man sollte das gleichzeitig frühzeitig erkennen. Und dieses Stigma, sich plötzlich zu einem Nervenarzt oder Psychiater zu begeben oder zum Psychologen zu begeben, das ist das eigentliche Problem. Dass wir eigentlich solche Krankheiten oder psychische Störungen einfach stigmatisieren als Abnormen. Und deswegen trauen sich Personen, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, sich nicht dazu zu bekennen.
Genau.
Ja, das ist natürlich aber auch ein Grundsatzproblem des Sports, dass du dich immer mit anderen misst. Und deswegen das Gefühl hast, du darfst nichts erkennen lassen, was dir aus Schwäche ausgelegt werden kann. Und das ist natürlich genau jetzt wieder bei einer psychischen Krankheit. Könnte mir der Trainer, der ein geringes Vorwissen über Depressionen hat, mir das als Schwäche auslegen. Ah ja, der ist ja psychisch labil. Der hat ja schon mal eine Depression. Diesen Spieler kaufe ich lieber nicht, weil vielleicht gefällt er wieder an eine Depression. Und aus dem gleichen Grund verschweigen ja auch viele Spieler ihre Knieverletzungen. Weil jetzt Robert in Hannover gespielt hat, da gab es auch einen Spieler, Valerian Ismael, der konnte nicht mehr sich richtig nach rechts drehen, weil sein Knie diese Drehung nicht mehr zugelassen hat. Das hat er natürlich auch versucht zu verschweigen und ihm im Spiel zu vertuschen. Also dieses Grundproblem werden wir im Sport fürchtig immer haben, dass die Sportler dazu neigen oder glauben, es vertuschen zu müssen. Aber ich denke schon, wir müssen deswegen umso mehr auch in den Sport die Klarheit reinbringen, den Leuten den Entscheidern im Sport klar machen. Ein Sportler, der punktuell unter einer Depression leidet, der kann genauso wie ein Spieler, der einen Kreuzbandriss erlitt, gesund zurückkommen und ist danach in den meisten Fällen 100 Prozent wieder leistungsfähig. Diese Botschaft, glaube ich, muss man dem Sport reinbringen. Und dann wird man aber immer noch das Problem haben, dass viele Sportler denken, alles, was mir eventuell negativ oder schwächer ausgelegt werden kann, das will ich lieber nicht, dass das irgendjemand in meiner Tranche, in meinem Verein mitkriegt. Also dieses Problem wird schwierig zu lösen sein.
Das hat auch ein anonymer Bundesligaprofi Michael Rosentritt gesagt. Das ist derjenige, der die Sebastian Deisler Biografie geschrieben hat im Jahr 2010. Das heißt, ein Jahr nach dem Tod von Robert Enke hat er Zitat gesagt, diese Krankheit, die als Sinnbild für Schwäche und Versagen steht, passt nicht zu unserem Leistungssystem. Es wird schwer, eine Selbsthilfegruppe zu finden, weil jeder froh ist, sich damit nicht identifizieren zu müssen. Und das lenkt, finde ich, Herr Dr. Henkel, ja auch schon so ein bisschen den Blick darauf, welche Angebote gibt es denn für Profisportler hier in dem Bereich, sprechen wir jetzt gerade, über Fußball, sich Hilfe zu suchen. Kann man da zum eigenen Teamarzt gehen, denn da greift er genau diese Angst vielleicht, dass das als Schwäche ausgelegt wird und ich dann im nächsten Spiel nicht mehr aufgestellt werde oder vielleicht sogar ganz aus dem Kader fliege?
Das kommt immer ganz drauf an, welche Situation man vor Ort vorfindet. Es gibt sicherlich besser informierte Teambetreuer, Trainer, Angehörige, die damit sicherlich vertrauensvoll und gut umgehen. Und es gibt welche, die das in der Tat als falsch verstehen und als Schwäche auslegen würden. Teamarzt wäre sicherlich vielleicht ein gar nicht so schlechter Ansprechpartner aus dem Grund, weil der natürlich einer ärztlichen Schweigepflicht auch unterliegt und jetzt auch da nichts weitergeben darf. Wir würden auch nicht empfehlen, dass man die Sache an die große Glocke hängt. Unbedingt würde man ja auch in anderen Berufsgruppen nicht unbedingt seinen Chef sagen, welche Krankheit man hat, ist man ja nicht unbedingt zu verpflichtet. Vielmehr ist es wichtig, dass dann entsprechende Maßnahmen eingeleitet werden und dass man offen mit zum Beispiel dem Teamarzt sprechen kann, dass sozusagen nicht nur ein körperliches Problem vorliegt, sondern dass man möglicherweise auch nicht erklärliche Dinge sich gerade abspielen, die dann in Richtung auch einer Depression laufen können. Und dass natürlich die Sportmediziner oder Ärzte, die damit beschäftigt sind, ein bisschen Sensibilität haben dafür und sich auch am besten einen Partner suchen oder einen Ansprechpartner suchen, wo die Sportler dann versorgt werden können, wo sie sich weiterhin wenden können, um eine spezifische Diagnostik hinsichtlich von psychischen Erkrankungen kommen können, wenn man merkt, dass es in diese Richtung geht. Ja, also in der Folge des Suizids von Robert Enke und diesem katastrophalen Ausgang hat sich die Deutsche Gesellschaft für Psychiatrie, Psychotherapie, Psychosomatik und Nervenheilkunden, also die Fachgesellschaft, auch mal Gedanken gemacht, gemeinsam mit dem DFB, der DFL und Hannover 96. Und man hat dann in der Folge sowohl die Robert Enke-Stiftung gegründet, als aber auch parallel dann etwas später ein Referat für Sportpsychiatrie und Psychotherapie. Und wir haben die Zeit in der Zwischenzeit genutzt, um so ein bisschen Versorgungsstruktur aufzubauen, wo wir einzelne Zentren, zwischen zehn universitäre Zentren für psychische Gesundheit im Sport haben, wo wir sportpsychiatrische Sprechstunden anbieten, wo sich Sportler hinwenden können und auch versuchen, ein ambulantes Netzwerk drum herum zu bauen. Und das ein Anlaufstationen für psychisch erkrankte Sportler gibt.
Das ist, glaube ich, wirklich ein großer, ein gewaltiger Fortschritt im Vergleich zu den Zeiten vor Robert Enke. Also Robert zum Beispiel musste ja wirklich alleine mit seiner Frau, mit seinem Berater autodidaktisch noch suchen, an wen wende ich mich eigentlich? Und ich glaube, er hat tatsächlich dann vier Psychotherapeuten ausprobiert, bis er überhaupt jemanden gefunden hat, zu dem er das Vertrauen hatte, wo er das Gefühl hatte, der kennt sich auch, der versteht mich als Sportler. Das war Valentin Marx in Köln, der selber mal ein Spitzenhandball-Torwart gewesen war, Europapokalsieger. Und heutzutage auch, ich glaube, schon durch die Bekanntheit der Robert Enke-Stiftung, das haben auch Sportler im Hinterkopf. Also wenn jetzt ein Sportler so weit ist, der schwierigste Schritt, er hat das selbst erkannt, er leidet unter Depressionen und er gesteht sich selbst ein, ich muss mich behandeln lassen und der braucht tatsächlich nur irgendwie im Hinterkopf haben. Es gibt auch diese Robert Enke-Stiftung und die stellt den Kontakt zu dieser Versorgungsstruktur, die der Herr Dr. Henkel gerade beschrieben hat, her. Und diese Struktur ist auf Sportler auch spezialisiert und ausgerichtet. Und das ist etwas ganz Neues und ich glaube auch durchaus fast Einmaliges auf der Welt, dass es das in Deutschland gibt.
Und gleichzeitig bleibt natürlich aber trotzdem immer die Angst, was passiert, wenn die Sache rauskommt. Also das kann man in jeder Biografie nachlesen, die sich mit Sportlern, die Depressionen haben, befasst. Man geht nie ohne Baseballcap zu seiner Therapie. Jetzt mal spitz gezeichnet, man möchte nicht erkannt werden. Und wir haben ja gerade auch mit Sebastian Deisler, der 2003 an Depressionen bekannt gegeben hat und 2007 dann nach einer zweiten Phase seine Karriere beendet hat, da hat man ja im Negativen die ganze Klaviatur gesehen, die da gespielt werden kann von den Medien. Also mit Boulevardberichten, wo dokumentiert wurde, wer besucht ihn in der Klinik, wann fanden diese Besuche statt, sind vielleicht die mysteriösen Freunde einer der Gründe, warum dieser hochtalentierte, einer der hochtalentiertesten Spieler seiner Generation nicht zu seiner Leistung findet. Da wurde diese ganze Boulevardklaviatur gespielt. Ist da vielleicht auch viel kaputt gegangen?
Nein, das würde heute nicht mehr passieren. Ich würde das Haus, das ich nicht besitze, verwenden. Nehmen Sie den ganz anderen Krankheitsfall, Mario Götze, da haben Sie nichts darüber gelesen. Das wurde absolut respektiert. Das ist tatsächlich, glaube ich, zu meinen eine Lehre aus dem Fall Robert Enke, dass in solchen Fällen tatsächlich die Medien sensibler geworden sind und das Gefühl haben, sie müssen den Sportler Zeit geben für die Heilung und ihn alleine lassen. Der Fall Sebastian Beisler hat sich in der Tat abgespielt zwischen 2003 und 2007. Ich glaube, er war sehr gut betreut fachlich in München, im Max-Planck-Institut. Aber diese ganzen Begleiterscheinungen, die wird es heute nicht mehr geben.
Das stelle ich mir als eine der größten Hürde vor, dieses Brennglas der Öffentlichkeit, unter dem man steht.
Sie haben ja auch richtig gesagt, Sie gehen da mit der Baseballmütze hinten. Sie müssen daran denken, dass jemand, der unter Depressionen leidet, auch unter diesem Gefühl, die ganze Welt starte mich doch jetzt an, unter dieser Patientenwahrnehmung. Der will sich auch ein, sagen wir mal, Ihr Arzt, Ihr Allgemeinarzt in München, wenn der unter Depressionen leidet, dann leidet er auch unter dem Gefühl, oh Gott, ich bin doch Arzt, was denken denn meine Patienten jetzt, wenn ich depressiv bin? Also auch der hat dieses Gefühl des Versteckens vielleicht. Das ist Teil der Krankheit. Und auch jemand, der einen Spitzen-Sportler, der unter einem Kreuzbandriss leidet, der wird mit der Angst zurückkehren. Zum einen finde ich meine Form wieder und kriege ich noch einen Vertrag. Da wird ja auch mein Knie durchgecheckt. Also diese Angst ist auch bei physischen Verletzungen dann da. Ich glaube, sie müsste heute nicht größer sein bei einem Sportler, der unter einer Depression leidet. Ich glaube, er hat sehr gute Chancen, dass er einen Verein findet, der versteht, dass man nach einer Depression wieder der gleiche Fußballer oder sogar der bessere Fußballer als vorher sein kann. Das wird nicht jeder Verein sein, aber ich bin ziemlich optimistisch, dass dieser Sportler – ich kenne auch ein paar Beispiele – dann wieder einen Verein findet und seine Karriere fortsetzen kann.
Es wäre ja auch nicht begründet, jemanden nach einer Depression nicht wieder einzustellen, weil im Gegensatz vielleicht zu einem Knie, das nach einem Kreuzbandriss gewisse Instabilitäten vielleicht noch beherbergt, heilt eine Depression ja komplett ab und man hat hinterher ja keine Restsymptome mehr.
Andererseits hat man aber natürlich auch den prominenten Fall Andreas Biermann, der in seinem Buch schreibt und davon berichtet, dass seinem Berater mehrfach von Vereinen abgesagt wurde mit Hinweis auf seine depressive Erkrankung. Und dieses ganze Buch ist noch mal doppelt bitter zu lesen, weil man weiß, am Ende des Buches scheint er geheilt und er hat im Jahr 2014 Selbstmord begangen.
Andreas Biermann hatte eine sehr, sehr schwere Depression. Er litt in einer Wiederkehr an Depressionen, die ich von keinem anderen Sportler kannte. Also es kamen immer wieder Depressionen. Und auch er hat aber, als er seine Depression bekannt gemacht hat, als er versucht hat zu studieren, ein neues Leben zu finden, hat er durchaus viel Unterstützung erfahren. Und auch bei ihm ist es wirklich schwierig abzugrenzen, weil er war immer ein Fußballer auf der Kippe. Also er hatte sich ja nie etabliert im Profifußball. Er war jetzt auch nicht ein Spieler, nachdem sich die Vereine umgedreht haben. Und da kann es durchaus sein, dass dann der eine Verein gesagt hat, ja Andreas Biermann, er hat was, aber er hat jetzt bei St. Pauli ja auch nicht gespielt. Und vielleicht hat dann Ander noch fälschlicherweise dann gesagt, okay, und dann kommt noch diese Depression oben drauf. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass man diesen Fall verallgemeinern kann. Das ist – Andreas Biermann hätte, glaube ich, auch ohne die Depression, muss man so sagen, er war ein ganz toller, lieber Mensch. Ich habe ihn zweimal getroffen. Wir haben uns wirklich toll mit ihm unterhalten. Ein Mensch, in dem man sich wohlfühlt. Aber auch ohne seine Depression muss man das objektiv sagen, hätte er Probleme gehabt, im Profifußball eine dauerhafte Karriere zu starten. Weil er war in der Bewertung der Trainer nie einer, wo jetzt 20 Vereine gesagt haben, den Spieler müssen wir haben.
Wir dürfen vielleicht auch nicht ganz vergessen, dass natürlich depressive Symptome auch nicht ausschließlich bei einer reinen depressiven Episode auftreten, sondern auch mal co-mobit, also das heißt zusammen auftreten mit anderen Störungsbildern sein können. Wir reden zum Beispiel von sowas wie Abhängigkeitserkrankungen, Alkoholsucht, vielleicht auch Angststörungen, Traumatisierung, Traumafolgestörungen. Das tritt natürlich dann häufiger dann auch zusammen auf. Also nicht, dass sozusagen die Depression predisponiert dafür, das alles andere zu bekommen, sondern umgekehrt, dass Depression sich manchmal auf ein anderes Störungsbild draufsetzt. Aber die allermeisten Fälle von Depression sind natürlich isoliert und unabhängig von anderen Störungsbildern.
Ja, und die Ironie ist ja, wenn wir sagen, kann ein Sportler nach der Depression auch leistungsfähig sein. Die tragische und traurige Ironie ist, dass das Robert Enke seinen sportlichen Höhepunkt nach seiner ersten schweren Depression erreicht hat. Also er war – ich glaube, da sind wir uns wahrscheinlich dann alle einig – er war nie besser als Torwart als in den Jahren 2004 bis 2009. Und er spielte da mit einer ganz großen Ruhe. Und ich meine, aus der Nähe zu ihm auch, hatte ich schon immer das Gefühl, es spielte eine große Rolle, dass er diese erste Depression, die erste schwere, schwerwiegende klinische Depression 2003, dass er die so gut überstanden hat. Das gab ihm, hatte ich das Gefühl, nochmal neue Kraft, nochmal ein Gefühl dafür, hey, ich habe was wirklich Schweres überstanden. Die Schwierigkeiten des Sports hauen mich jetzt nicht mehr so schnell um. Selbst Robert bei der zweiten Depression, der das tragische Beispiel ist, wie eine Depression vernichtend enden kann, selbst er, seinen Lebensweg, gibt ein Beispiel, wie ein Sportler nach einer Depression in fabelhafter Form und sehr gesund wiederkommen kann.
Das ist das, was der To-20er ja auch in seiner Rede bei der Trauerfeier, bei der Beerdigung von Robert Enke gesagt hat. Er sagte unter anderem nicht nur das, was wir vorhin im Intro gehört haben, sondern auch Fußball ist nicht alles und es geht um viel, viel mehr im Leben. Aber allein, dass man diesen Satz sagen muss und dass man da auch ins Krübeln kommt, zeigt ja auch, für manche ist Fußball dann doch schon zumindest sehr viel. Und der Leistungsdruck ist ja auch sehr hoch. Gleichzeitig auch die öffentliche Wahrnehmung und ja auch die Bewertung. Also wir befinden uns hier im Bereich des Sports und beim Fußball besonders, weil es eben der Volkssport in Deutschland ist, wird jede Leistung bewertet. Und jetzt hat ein Journalist ja auch die Aufgabe, auch schlechte Leistungen einzuordnen. Wie geht man denn als Berichterstatter über den Fußball mit dem Wissen um? Es gibt Spieler, die könnten auch an diesem Leistungsdruck zerbrechen.
Ja, aber wir dürfen das jetzt nicht vermischen. Also wenn ich als Journalist eine fiese, persönliche Bewertung schreibe von einem Sportler, dann trifft das einen nicht depressiven Sportler vielleicht genauso oder genauso mehr wie einen depressiven Sportler. Und es wird auch, glaube ich, nicht den Fall geben, dass man oder man kann nicht sagen, ein Sportler ist total gesund und dann kommt Ronald Reng und vernichtet den im Eintickel und daraufhin wird er depressiv. So funktionieren Depressionen nicht. Aber da werden jetzt so zwei Sachen zusammengeworfen. Und damals war einfach nach dem Tod Roberts eine große Betroffenheit da. Und die Leute hatten das Gefühl, sie wollen Gutes tun. Sie haben sich selber verletzt gefühlt, angegriffen, wollten Gutes tun. Und da kamen diese Gedanken aus, die Theo Zwanziger in seiner Rede aufgestanden hat. Wir sollen doch besser miteinander umgehen. Aber das hat eigentlich nichts mit Roberts Krankheit, der Depression zu tun. Das ist ein ganz, ganz anderes Themenfeld. Und man kann auch wirklich nicht realistisch erwarten, dass aufgrund des Todes, so tragisch und niederschmetternd er ist, aufgrund des Todes eines einzigen Sportler, sich plötzlich der ganze Umgang unter uns Menschen ändert. Das war durchaus eine absurde Erwartung an die Zeit nach Roberts Tod. Ich glaube, das Einzige, was man nach dem Tod von Robert erwarten durfte, ist, dass wir uns tatsächlich mehr mit dieser Krankheit befassen, dass wir versuchen, den Leuten, die unter dieser Krankheit leiden, bessere Hilfe zu verfügen zu stellen. Das ist gerade im Sport auch dank solcher Institute wie von Dr. Henkel in Aachen gelungen. Dass die Betreuung dieser Sportler besser ist und das Wissen über Depressionen ist natürlich noch nicht bis zu jedem, hat noch nicht jeden durchdrungen. Aber auch in den Vereinen gibt es viel mehr Mitarbeiter als vorher, die ein vages Verständnis von Depressionen haben und die auch verstehen, dass ein depressiver Sportler nicht das Ende der Karriere oder das Ende der Welt bedeutet, sondern dass man dem helfen kann und helfen muss.
Und dann hatten wir noch den Fall Babak Rafati, wo auch Druck eine Rolle gespielt hat, aber bei ihm kommen auch viele Dinge zusammen. Bei ihm geht es auch sehr um den internen Druck, den er durch den DFB bekommen hat, durch Helmut Krug und Herrn Pfandl, aber schon auch um die öffentliche Rolle eines Schiedsrichters, der ja tatsächlich noch mal ein bisschen rausgelöst steht. Also ich würde fast sagen, in manchen Situationen ist der Schiedsrichter der gemeinsame Gegner, sogar der gegnerischen Mannschaft. Und manchmal hat man den Eindruck, dass es sich darauf konzentriert. Stehen die da noch mal in so einer Sonderrolle da, oder muss man da auch vorsichtig sein, jetzt nicht Einzelschicksale zu sehr zu überspitzen und zu generalisieren?
Also nach meinem Verständnis von Depressionen gibt es, kann die Frau, die Kassiererin beim Lidl-Supermarkt, die kann das genauso als Stress, als Überforderung empfinden, der eine Depression auslöst, dass sie den ganzen Tag nur Zahlen eintippt und keiner noch nicht mal Hallo zu ihr sagt, wie ein Schiedsrichter ein traumatisches Erlebnis bei ihm eine Depression auslöst. Es ist super, wenn wir es schaffen, die Schiedsrichter menschlicher zu behandeln, aber da besteht kein Zusammenhang, dass wir sie besser behandeln müssen, um sie vor Depressionen zu schützen.
Herr Dr. Henkel, wo gibt es denn noch Potenziale, wo man jetzt im Fußball und vielleicht auch generell im Sport noch Strukturen schaffen könnte, neben dem Vermitteln von Wissen, das haben wir jetzt ja schon mehrfach direkt und indirekt angesprochen, um einen besseren Umgang mit Depressionen, mit depressiven Sportlern zu schaffen?
Gut, also, wie gesagt, ich glaube, die Vernetzung spielt eine Rolle. Das heißt, die Vernetzung zwischen den Sportärzten, zwischen den Sportpsychologen, die in den Vereinen, in den Verbänden tätig sind und den letztlich Fachpsychotherapeuten oder Fachärzten, die psychische Erkrankungen behandeln, das ist, glaube ich, wichtig, dass es so eine Durchlässigkeit gibt, dass es einen Zusammenarbeiten gibt, dass es einen gemeinsamen Austausch gibt, dass jeder weiß, wo seine Fähigkeiten und Grenzen sind. Anderes Thema zum Beispiel auch dieser Übergangsbereich zwischen Kinder und Jugend, Sport und psychiatrischen Störungsbildern und dem Erwachsenenbereich, auch da gibt es so Risikokonstellationen, wenn der Sport im Nachwuchsbereich ganz gut funktioniert und man hat eine eigene Erwartung, dass man jetzt ein gutes Talent ist und dann so in eine Erwachsenenmannschaft nach der A-Jugend übergenommen wird. Das können dann Brüche sein, können Lokalveränderungen sein, dass man jetzt woanders hinzieht, in einen Verein transferiert, auch ins Ausland vielleicht, dass plötzlich das unterstützende Familiensystem in einem frühen Stadium der Entwicklung schon nicht mehr da ist. Das sind auch neue Stressfaktoren. Da ist es ganz wichtig, dass gerade die verschiedenen Bereiche der psychiatrischen und psychotherapeutischen Behandler in den verschiedenen Altersbereichen miteinander kommunizieren können. Wir haben ja so ein System, wonach Kinder und Jugendliche meistens vor 18 von den Kindern und Jugendpsychotheren und Psychotherapeuten behandelt werden und nach 18 von Erwachsenen. Das sind gerade mal so kritische Phasen, die den Übergang bedeuten. Das sind zum Beispiel Aspekte und wie gesagt die Vernetzung zum Sportbetreuern, die noch näher dran sind direkt im Alltag. Das sind so Aspekte, die wir bearbeiten und sie als Ziel unserer künftigen Aufgaben auch noch mal machen, neben der natürlich weiteren Verbreitung in der Fläche vor Ort.
Jetzt habe ich auch losgelöst nur vom Thema Depression im Fußball in einem Artikel aus dem Jahr 2015 gelesen, dass auf ein Erstgespräch bei einem Psychotherapeuten man in Deutschland durchschnittlich drei Monate warten muss. Das hat die Bundespsychotherapeutenkammer errechnet. Und in ländlichen Regionen sind es sogar noch mehr Monate, im Brandenburg 5. Und bei dem Termin ist es auch nur die Bestandsaufnahme, nicht der Therapiebeginn. Das heißt, wir haben ja gleichzeitig auch eine Situation eines Mangels an behandelnden Ärzten. Oder hat sich an dieser Situation seit 2015 auch schon wieder was getan?
Gute Psychotherapie wird ja nicht nur von Ärzten, sondern auch von psychologischen Psychotherapeuten durchgeführt, vielleicht sogar ein bisschen mehr als von Ärzten. Aber einen Mangel gibt es immer noch. Und das ist ein bisschen regional unterschiedlich. Hier in Aachen ist es ein bisschen besser, in anderen Regionen ist es noch schlechter, wie Sie sagen, im ländlichen Bereich. Und das ist weiterhin ein großes Problem. Und man könnte sicherlich noch viel mehr bewirken, wenn man noch mehr Therapeuten zur Verfügung hat. Andererseits bringt das auch nichts, sagen wir mal, zu irgendjemand hinzugehen, der keine spezifische psychotherapeutische Ausbildung hat. Weil, sagen wir mal, irgendeine Intervention muss nicht immer eine gute Intervention sein. Und es gibt Versuche, sowas zu überbrücken. Es gibt zum Beispiel online gestützte Psychotherapieverfahren, die man manche Krankenkassen zum Beispiel anbieten, wo man gewisse Informationen auch schon über Computerprogramme erhält. Und teilweise sind die dann auch von Therapeuten supervidiert. Manche laufen von alleine. Die endgültige Einschätzung dieser Überbrückungsmethoden ist noch nicht ganz da, aber das sind so neue Ansätze. Man sich hier Gedanken macht, wie kann man Psychotherapie denn so mehr noch in die Breite bekommen und dass man möglichst viele Menschen erreicht.
Kann man das irgendwie erklären, warum psychische Erkrankungen sich so verbreiten in unserer jetzigen Zeit? Man liest da immer viele Allgemeinplätze vom Druck, der auf jedem herrschen würde, von der Arbeitsbelastung, die wir alle haben, von der ständigen Bombardierung mit neuen Nachrichten, also auch dem, dass man das Ruhezeiten manchmal fehlen. Ich tue mich ehrlich gesagt aber immer schwer, mit so allgemeinen Gesellschaftsbeobachtungen dann so etwas zu unterfüttern, wie dass eine psychische Krankheit sich so zur Volkskrankheit entwickeln wird, auch in der Zukunft.
Die ist schon eine Volkskrankheit und sie ist durch alle Zeiten hin mal mehr, mal weniger präsent und wir werden sie auch nicht komplett verhindern können. Ich glaube, wichtig ist einfach, dass man in der Tat die Sache nicht schlimmer macht als sie ist, dass nicht noch gesellschaftliche Situationen da sind, die einen größeren sozialen Druck verursachen, größere Stressfaktoren verursachen, dass dadurch noch eine höhere Rate von Depressionen eine Rolle spielt. Aber im Wesentlichen wird es eine Depression immer geben. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich wichtig zu akzeptieren, dass Krankheiten sind, dass diese Krankheiten aber behandelbar sind, dass wir Leute aufmerksam sind, auch mit ihren Angehörigen. Wir erleben das ganz häufig, dass Personen sich nicht selber auf eigenen Wunsch vorstellen, sondern dass die Ehepartner, Eltern, Kinder sagen oder jemanden dazu bewegen, sich dann doch letztlich eine Therapie zu begeben. So ist es auch manchmal bei Sportlern. Dass dann der Trainer oder die Partner sich melden und sagen, komm, geh doch mal, hol dir Hilfe. Dass wir alle um unsere wichtigsten Bezugspersonen auch ein bisschen achtsamer sind. Ich glaube, das kann schon helfen, dass vielleicht nicht eine Depression verhindert wird, aber doch, dass eine Behandlung zum Beispiel eher eingeleitet werden kann.
Jetzt gibt es seit der Saison 2015 und seit 2016 in den Nachwuchsleistungszentren der 2. und 3. Liga muss es einen Pädagogen in Vollzeit und einen Psychologen in Teilzeit geben. Herr Reng, wie sind denn die Bundesliga-Vereine in dem Bereich aufgestellt? Man liest immer viel von Mental-Coaches. Da würde ich jetzt aber erstmal die Frage in den Raum stellen, ob das dann immer auch gleich Psychologen oder Psychotherapeuten sind, die sowas auch diagnostizieren könnten.
Ja, das ist erstmal ein grundlegender Unterschied. Also der Sportpsychologe – und ich glaube, mittlerweile sind es in den meisten Fällen bei den Bundesliga tatsächlich ausgebildete Psychologen – ist ja in erster Linie zur Leistungsoptimierung, das moderne Wort, und Steigerung da. Also da geht es nicht darum, Krankheiten zu erkennen oder gar zu therapieren. Der kann das auch gar nicht therapieren. Dazu braucht es einen Psychotherapeuten oder einen Psychiater dann. Aber ein gut ausgebildeter Psychologe und auch ein Psychologe, wie man sich ihn vorstellt, mit großer Empathie, der hat im Idealfall natürlich ein besseres Auge als der Assistenttrainer für diese Krankheiten. Aber wie gesagt, der ist nicht dafür da. Das wäre im besten Fall ein Nebenprodukt, wenn der auch nochmal eine Depression erkennt oder eine psychische Krankheit und sie dann in die richtige Wege leitet, den Jungen zur Behandlung schickt. Aber darum geht es da nicht in dem Fall. Es ist eine große Diskussion auch unter Psychiatern und Psychotherapeuten, die im Sport arbeiten. Sollte auch der Sportpsychiater beim Verein angestellt sein? Sollte es so eine Position geben? Oder sollte der eben gerade nicht beim Verein angestellt sein? Weil in dem Moment, wo er beim Verein angestellt ist, er ja Teil dieses Systems ist und es vielleicht dem Sportler dann schwerfällt, zu dem Psychiater eines Vereins zu gehen, weil er dann das Gefühl hätte, naja, der hat zwar die Schweigepflicht, aber ich weiß nicht, was sagt er nicht doch dem Trainer? Also das ist bei manche denken, es ist besser, wie es jetzt ist, dass der Sportpsychiater außerhalb ist, dass der Sportler das Gefühl hat, er kann da hingehen und das alles ist weit weg und bleibt weg von dem Club. Während es andere Sportpsychiater gibt, die sagen, doch sie müssten näher dran sein, sie müssten auch Teil des Vereins sein, weil sie dann auch eben viel schneller und viel besser Krankheitsfälle erkennen können. Das ist ein Streit, eine Debatte klingt nicht so schlimm wie Streitfall unter den Sportpsychiatern selber. Es gibt aber, um das abzuschließen, soweit ich weiß, in keinem Fußballverein der Welt einen festangestellten Sportpsychiater, sondern es gibt diesen Psychologen, der durchaus auch mit psychischen Problemen wie Angstzustände, da kann er versuchen, daran zu arbeiten, die kann er abzustellen. Aber Depressionen erkennt er im besten Fall und überweist dann zum Kollegen.
Und hat das auch mit dem Bild des Sportlers zu tun, was sich so immer aufgebaut hat? Also im Fußball besonders noch der männliche, starke, der keine Schwächen zeigen darf, ein bisschen Draufgänger soll er sein, auch ein bisschen genial am liebsten, darf auch mal über die Stränge schlagen und muss aber auf dem Platz ordentlich hinlangen. Müsste man auch so ein bisschen das Bild des Sportlers, das man in Medien und vor allem in den Medien zeichnet, überdenken, um ein besseres Umfeld zu schaffen, wo mehr Verständnis für auch Kopfkrankheiten herrscht, das ist jetzt ein sehr banaler Begriff dafür, was ich meine, was ja aber als Schwäche gesehen wird. Also ein gebrochenes Bein ist ein gebrochenes Bein, da kann ich, doof gesagt, nichts für. Eine Depression, da sagen die Leute ja, jetzt habt ich doch bitte nicht so.
Naja, man muss ja erstmal festhalten, dass auf dem Fußballplatz und in dieser Klasse oder mit dieser Klasse, mit der heute Fußball gespielt wird, da kann man sich da in der Tat kaum noch Fehler und sozusagen Schwächen erlauben. Und aufgrund dieser Perfektion, die das Spiel auch erreicht hat, und wir feiern ja im Fernsehen, wir zeigen ja im Fernsehen eigentlich nur das Spiel und wir zeigen Schnipsel von Emotionen nach dem Spiel, indem wir verschwitzte Fußballer interviewen. Also da wird in diesen 90 Minuten plus Nachspielzeit natürlich das Bild des Zuschauers vom Sportler geprägt. Und da sehen wir in der Tat Sportler, die scheinbar auf dem Rasen frei von Schwächen sind. Und das Publikum schafft es oder will es auch gar nicht offenbar, umzuschwitzen und zu sagen, das sind aber trotzdem noch Menschen. Und in dem Moment, als sie vom Platz runtergehen, in dem Moment, wo sie ihr Berufsfeld, das sie auf fabelhafter Weise beherrschen, in dem Moment, in dem sie es verlassen, haben die selbstverständlich Sorgen, Ängste, Schwächen und auch psychische Krankheiten oder psychische Probleme wie andere auch. Dieser eigentlich ganz banale Transfer, dieser Gedanke, der findet nicht statt, weil wir in der Tat, wir oder das Publikum Sportler braucht, offenbar zum Ausgleich vom echten Leben. Also Sportler sind keine Figuren mehr aus dem echten Leben, sondern das sind die Figuren, wenn wir, dass die Zuschauer abschalten vom echten Leben und deswegen gestehen wir denen auch gar nicht mehr zu, dass sie Menschen sind wie wir. Wir wollen die überhöhen, wir wollen die sehen als fabelhafte Gladiatoren, fantastische Figuren einer Traumwelt von 90 Minuten, in der man seine Gefühle extrem ausleben kann. Verlieren, man weint, man schreit, man gewinnt, man fühlt sich endlich als Sieger. Und deswegen haben das Publikum, glaube ich, oder das Großteil des Publikums gar kein großes Interesse daran, den Sportler als Mensch kennenzulernen. Während ich vielleicht, was mein Job ist als Buchschreiber, erlebe, dass gerade Sportler, immer mehr Sportler eine große Sehnsucht danach haben, endlich mal alles zu erzählen. Also Andrew Agassi zum Beispiel, die Biografie, die er geschrieben hat. Und da gibt es ganz viele Sportler mittlerweile, die das Gefühl haben, die das Instinktiv vom Publikum übernommen haben. Diese Rolle, die sie spielen sollen, des Unverletzlichen. Sie meinen, sie müssten sich so geben, weil das erwartet wird. Und die aber dann das Gefühl haben, sie müssten etwas in sich reinfressen. Sie müssen etwas verbergen. Das ist völlig falsche Gefühl. Sie können eigentlich nie sie sein. Die also unbewusst übernehmen, den Glauben, sie müssten auch außerhalb des Platzes dieser unverwundbare Gladiator sein. Und irgendwann brechen da einige zusammen – oder eine Zusammenbrechung klingt schon wieder zu dramatisch – haben den Wunsch, einfach mal alles rauszuschreien und sich tatsächlich zu offenbaren, wie sie wirklich sind mit ihren Schwächen. Das passiert dann in Dokumentarfilmen oder in Biografien. Aber da erleben wir ja, dass das Publikum deutlich weniger diese Filme anschaut oder diese Biografien kauft, indem wirklich ohne Fassade einfach mal der Alltag auch erzählt wird. Sondern das Publikum will abschalten und das schafft es, benutzt den Sport als Mittel zum Abschalten und zieht deswegen nur diese 90 Minuten, interessieren ihn.
Ich denke, was auch eine Rolle spielt, ist, dass Sportler natürlich sehr disziplinierte Menschen sind. Jemand, der so viel – häufig wird ja die ganze Jugend und die ganze Freizeit in den Sport gesteckt. Häufig sind auch Familienmitglieder, die das pushen oder sich selber da auch eine Aufgabe schaffen. Und das führt natürlich dazu, dass es alles in gewisser Weise auch sehr kontrollierte Menschen sind, die natürlich eigentlich auch andere Bedürfnisse haben, aber sich nach außen hin natürlich sehr, sehr kontrolliert geben. Und gerade, wenn man zum Mannschaftssport geht, dann wird das ja auch nach außen gelebt. Wir sind eine Einheit und wir sind alles Freunde. Das wird sicherlich nicht so sein. Aber ich glaube, das kriegt jemand, der sich von Kindesbeinen an intensiv mit Sport beschäftigt und da Teil des Ganzen ist, natürlich auch so ein bisschen eingeimpft. Und ich glaube, deswegen haben wir häufig natürlich auch mit Personen zu tun, die so diesen Part, dieses Disziplinierte, dieses Strebsame schon internalisiert haben. Was aber nicht heißen muss, dass die emotionale Entwicklung irgendwie im gleichen Maße ist. Also wenn man mit Sportlern zu tun hat, hat man häufig sogar so eine gewisse Diskrepanz zwischen dem einerseits sehr nach außen Erwachsenen und diszipliniert wirkenden, vernünftig wirkenden Menschen. Andererseits aber so was wie eine, da fehlt es manchmal an anderen Aspekten, wie Organisationen, also die geben dann manches ab an ihr Umfeld und an andere, die sie organisieren und aber selber sich sozusagen eine normale Entwicklung nicht machen konnten. Und dann wird zumindest dann, wenn das Unterstützungssystem mal wegfällt oder wenn der Sport mal vorbei ist, geben sich dann neue Probleme. Wenn dann plötzlich man sozusagen auf eigenen Beinen stehen muss, aber bestimmte Skills so im Leben noch nicht erlernt hat.
Diese sehr hohe Disziplin, über die Sportler verfügen, war bei Robert Enke auch ein Fluch und Segen innerhalb seiner Depression, weil er zum einen, obwohl er von dieser Krankheit sehr gezeichnet war mit den Symptomen, dass er sich die ganze Zeit gestresst gefühlt hat, morgens eigentlich nicht mehr aus dem Bett wollte, trotzdem hat ihn die Disziplin immer noch funktionieren lassen als Fußballer. Er ist immer noch zum Training gefahren und konnte immer noch, obwohl er auch Antidepressiva genommen hat, konnte er noch so trainieren, dass es offenbar in seiner Mannschaft niemanden auffiel, dass er unter einer schweren Krankheit litt. Und das war einerseits natürlich gut für ihn. Er konnte sozusagen den Alltag aufrechterhalten, war aber vielleicht dann irgendwo auch dann doch der Fluch, weil er sich in Behandlung begeben, rausgehen aus dem Fußball und sich sechs Wochen, drei Monate, sechs Monate, wie lange es dauert, behandeln lassen. Diesen Schritt, zu dem wurde er nie gezwungen von seinem Körper, weil er irgendwie immer den Körper noch mit seiner Disziplin überlisten konnte und weiter funktioniert hatte. Das wäre im Nachhinein sicher für ihn besser gewesen, wenn er aufgegeben hätte und sich behandeln hätte lassen, was immer danach nach passiert wäre.
Ich glaube, das muss man noch mal festhalten, auch wenn wir es schon mal angedeutet haben. Die sportliche Leistung muss auch in einer depressiven Phase, selbst wenn es eine schwere, depressive Phase ist, nicht zwangsläufig darunter leiden. Andreas Biermann ist ein Beispiel dafür. Er lag im Trainingslager bis 5 Uhr morgens wach, weil er die Schlafstörungen hatte, die oft mit einer Depression einhergehen. Er hat trotzdem alle Trainingseinheiten, die gerade im Trainingslager besonders physisch sind, von vorne bis Ende mitgemacht. Holger Stanislavski, sein Trainer, konnte es im Nachhinein gar nicht glauben, dass er in dieser Phase so wenig Schlaf hatte und so schwer krank war, während er auf dem Platz immer noch eine Leistung gebracht hat, die absolut unauffällig in Anführungszeichen war.
Das sind hochtrainierte Sportler, die auch unter der Krankheit noch ihr Können bis zu einem gewissen Grad abrufen können. Es fällt dann keinen auf, wenn man es weiß, wenn man genau hinschaut. Als Robert tot war und als ich mir seine letzten Spiele, die er hochdepressiv bestritten hat, nochmal angeschaut hat. Wenn man das um die Krankheit weiß, dann sieht man schon, wie viel dabei ihm nicht stimmt. Zum Beispiel ein klares Symptom der Depression. Er hat nicht mehr geredet, er lief rum mit einem Gesicht, das einfach eine Maske war, auch während des Spiels. Da hat sich nichts mehr bewegt in diesem Gesicht. Das hat die komplette Gefühlslosigkeit ausgedrückt. Wie er die Bälle gehalten hat, seine Koordination war nicht mehr richtig. Er hat zwar die Bälle gehalten, aber wie er gesprungen ist, ein Arm hat zu weit gegriffen, er ist unrund abgerollt. In solchen Kleinigkeiten konnte man das schon erkennen. Martin Amedick hat mir erzählt, der Kaiserslautern hat während des Cirkel-Trainings, also einem sehr hartes Training, als er das Depressiv bestritten hat, permanent Krämpfe gekriegt. Er hat dann immer vorgetäuscht, er müsste schnell mal was trinken, eine Trinkpause machen. So ist es niemandem aufgefallen. Die können das abrufen bis zu einem gewissen Grad, aber die absolute Top-Leistung bringen sie in dem Moment nicht mehr, wenn sie unter einer schwerwiegenden Depression leiden.
Herr Dr. Henkel, Sie haben jetzt vorhin schon einmal kurz angesprochen, dass es ja auch noch diesen Wechsel gibt. Einmal haben wir gesprochen von Jugend in den Profibereich und quasi von Jugendpsychiater bis hin zu einem Erwachsenenpsychiater. Und jetzt gibt es ja aber auch noch den sportlichen Wechsel von der Karriere hin zum Karriereende. Und ich habe gelesen, dass gerade bei Männern statistisch erwiesen die Anfälligkeit für Depressionen auch oft mit dem, ich glaube, Gratifizierung nannte man das. Also wenn zum Beispiel das Ausbleiben einer Gehaltserhöhung oder eben Verabschiedung in den Ruhestand. Können wir das auch im Sport beobachten, dass Sportler, also dann Ex-Sportler, in diesen Momenten nochmal besonders anfällig sind?
Ohne Frage. Wir sehen das ja auch bei Leuten, die normalerweise im Berufsleben ausscheiden, weil sie in Rente gehen. Nur sind diese Leute meistens Mitte 60. Und so ein Sportler ist dann vielleicht Mitte 30. Und wenn er sich früh verletzt, vielleicht auch Mitte 20. Und das heißt natürlich etwas. Da verändert sich ganz viel im gesamten System. Das heißt, man kriegt nicht mehr, wie Sie sagen, diese Gratifikation, also diese Belohnung durch Sport, durch Einsätze, Nominierung, Erfolge, Siege. Man hat nicht mehr die Anerkennung vielleicht in der eigenen Familie. Man bekommt dort eine neue Rolle. Man hat jetzt plötzlich Aufgaben, die dem Alltag entsprechen und nicht mehr, sagen wir mal, so eine Nebenrolle zu Hause. Man bekommt finanzielle Änderungen. Es ist nicht häufig, viele haben keine parallele Ausbildung gemacht, und die stehen zunächst erst mal ohne Beruf da. Ganz häufig ist es so, dass sich innerhalb weniger Jahre Partnerschaften und Ehen auflösen. Und daneben kommen vielleicht Folgeerkrankungen vom Sport, chronische Schmerzen, Gelenkstörungen, also ein doch vorgealteter Körper. Und so, dass viele Dinge zusammenkommen, das ganze System ändert sich. Und das kann zum einen relativ früh passieren, weil Leistungssport nicht lange zu betreiben ist in den meisten Sportarten. Und es kann sogar ganz plötzlich kommen, von einem auf dem anderen Tag ist der Kreuzbandriss da oder eine andere schwere Verletzung und es geht nicht mehr weiter. Und da sind die wenigsten darauf vorbereitet oder man sollte sich gut darauf vorbereiten, gerade was so ein absehbares Ende betrifft. Aber nicht jeder macht sich da in jungen Alter schon Gedanken drum. Und das ist natürlich in einer wirklichen Risikokonstellation dann in der Tat dann auch hatten die Strukturen nicht mehr regelmäßiges Training, nicht mehr die selben Leute um sich herum. Man muss sich plötzlich um sowas alles selber kümmern. Und das ist in der Tat ein sehr großes Risiko.
Was tun da die Bundesliga-Vereine und auch höherklassige Amateur-Vereine, Herr Reng, um solchen Spielern zu helfen? Gibt es da schon Strukturen oder lässt man die überspitzt gesagt fallen?
Ja, der Fußballprofi ist der Angestellte des Vereins. In dem Moment, wo sein Vertrag endet, ist er nicht mehr angestellt und dann wird er verabschiedet. Es gibt Strukturen, gibt es keine. Es gibt einzelne Versuche, wie tauglich die sind, um Leuten ein neues Leben zu gestalten, ist auch fraglich. Aber es gibt jetzt mehr Traditionsvereine. Es gibt Vereine, die machen Feriencamps für Kinder und stellen dafür als Trainer alte Spieler an. Vielen Spielern im Ruhestand gibt es tatsächlich noch etwas, die Verbindung zu ihren besten Jahren, im Berufsjahren, irgendwie dabei bleiben beim Verein. Kann aber sicher nicht das Allheilmittel sein. Ich denke, bei der Mehrzahl der Spieler sollte es ja auch darum gehen, in dem Moment, wo sie aufhören, dass sie loskommen vom Fußball, dass sie etwas Neues finden. Und wenn man da Strukturen schaffen würde, ich spinne jetzt ein bisschen rum, da müsste man ja quasi eine Hochschule für Fußballer oder eine Berufsbildungsstätte für Fußballspieler schaffen. Das gibt es nicht. Weiß ich auch nicht, ob es das geben muss oder geben soll. Ich denke, das ist ja auch eine tolle Herausforderung für jeden Menschen, dass er mit 30 nochmal neu startet. Aber es ist in der Tat so. Ich glaube, ich habe in den 25 Jahren, in denen ich jetzt in der Fußballbranche arbeite, einen einzigen Fußballer getroffen. Deswegen ist es mir auch so hängen geblieben, der zu mir gesagt hat, er findet Fußballprofi ist so ein toller Beruf, weil da kann man mit 30 nochmal ganz neu anfangen. Das war ein Spieler von Bayern München, Dieter Frei hieß der. Der hat danach studiert und ist Lehrer geworden. Aber diesen Blickwinkel kann man wahrscheinlich auch nicht erwarten, dass das die Mehrheit hat. Für die Mehrheit ist Fußball der Beruf, in dem sie ihre ganze Jugend exzessiv darauf hingearbeitet haben. Es ist ein Beruf, in dem ihnen das ganze Umfeld einredet. Es sei ein Traumberuf. Und da bleibt bei den wenigsten die Zeit an etwas anderes zu denken. Und die meisten müssen sich das auf die harte Art erarbeiten. Was machen sie in den verbleibenden 60, 70 Jahren ihres Lebens?
Wäre das nicht vielleicht auch eine der Aufgaben, die der Vertragsspieler, also der VDV, übernehmen könnte? Der hat ja auch unter anderem das VDV-Profikamp, wo sich Profis fit halten können, die vertragslos sind. Müsste ja eigentlich aus dieser Richtung kommen, so ein Impuls.
Die versuchen das in der Tat mit ihren kleinen Mitteln. Die Gewerkschaft der deutschen Fußballspieler oder der Interessensverband der deutschen Fußballspieler, muss man aber auch ehrlich sagen, ist sehr schwach, was die Struktur angeht, was seine Struktur angeht, was die Gelder angeht, die ihnen zur Verfügung stehen. Also die versuchen, Sachen zu machen, bei der Berufsfortbildung Sportlern zu helfen, aber das kann immer nur ein kleiner Tropfen sein. In England zum Beispiel ist die PFA, die Professional Football Association, die Gewerkschaft der Fußballer, finanziell deutlich besser. Die können da deutlich mehr machen. Die machen zum Beispiel auch sowas, wie man leicht zynisch als Zwangssparplan bezeichnen könnte. Jeder Spieler, der in der Premier League spielt, auch wenn er aus Bulgarien kommt, zahlt einen Teil seines Gehaltes zwangsweise in eine Altersversicherung ein und die verwaltet die PFA und die wird dem Sportler dann mit 40, glaube ich, dann ausgezahlt, wenn man davon ausgeht, da ist er dann an einem Punkt, wo er eine neue Karriere starten sollte. Solche Mittel gibt es, aber im Großen und Ganzen obliegt es dann doch immer dem individuellen Fußballer, was zu machen mit seinem Leben. Wenn ich da vergleiche, so die jetzige Generation, die tatsächlich eigentlich seit sie elf, zwölf sind, in Nachwuchsleistungszentren auf diesen Sport, auf dieses Berufsziel Fußballprofi, hinarbeiten. Bei denen ist ja selbst die Schule nachrangig. Die gehen zwar zur Schule und da wird auch immer gesagt, ja, die Schule ist wichtig, aber wenn einer mit 17 vor der Profi-Karriere steht, und das habe ich bei ganz normalen Profi-Spieler, bei 1860 München erlebt, Richard Neudecker, Wittek, die spielen jetzt beide in der zweiten Liga, in Heidenheim und St. Pauli, wenn es dann Schwierigkeiten gibt in der Schule, dann wird halt das Abitur doch nicht gemacht, sondern mit 17 schon in der A-Jugend professionell gespielt. Und für die – jetzt habe ich ein bisschen ausgeholt – für die ist es, glaube ich, nochmal viel schwieriger, mit 32 etwas anderes zu machen als für die Generation vor 20, 30 Jahren, die auch immer wussten, also die schon als Jugendliche vielleicht in einem Beruf gelernt haben und die auch immer irgendwie wussten, auch wenn sie zehn Jahre Fußballprofi sind, wenn sie Glück haben, verdienen sie genug, dass sie damit einen tollen Betrieb aufmachen können, aber sie werden wieder arbeiten müssen. Und dieses Wissen haben die heutigen Spieler ja nicht. Also die vielen, viele wissen ja eigentlich, wenn sie mit dem Geld gut haushalten, dann könnte das ja sogar für ein Leben lang reichen. Nur ohne Beschäftigung, ohne die Struktur, und tagtäglich kommen dann doch viele nicht zurecht, und viele kommen auch nicht damit zurecht, ihr Geld zu verwalten. Und die Zahlen sind ja in der Tat schockierend, wie viel Fußballer Millionen verdienen und am Ende der Karriere Pfennige haben.
Woher kriegt denn die PFA in England ihr Geld? Kommt das vom Verband oder von den Spielern, von den Vereinen, von der Liga? Geld gibt es ja im Fußball.
Ja, aus Halbwissen, was zusammenreimen, ich glaube von allen Quellen. Ich meine auch, dass die Spieler auch da zwangsweise was einzahlen, was in Deutschland, wenn dann deutlich geringer der Fall ist, aber dass auch die Vereine in England deutlich höhere Abgaben zahlen. Das ist einfach eine stärkere Tradition. Also die VDV in Deutschland, der Interessensverein der deutschen Profifußballer, wurde irgendwann in den 80er- oder 90er-Jahren gegründet, meine ich. Die PFA existiert seit, weiß ich nicht, übertrieben gesagt 100 Jahren. Da steckt eine andere Kraft dahinter. Sie merken aber in England auch, gerade jetzt habe ich mit Per Mertesacker, der bei Arsenal London demnächst die Nachwuchsakademie leiten wird, übernimmt, mit dem habe ich darüber gesprochen. In England ist Fußballprofi ja auch mit 16 ein richtiger Ausbildungsberuf. Also die gehen in den Verein, so wie bei uns die Dachdecker in die Berufsschule gehen, machen die noch nebenbei Schule, aber die lernen den Beruf Fußballprofi mit 16. Und von diesen Jungs, die mit 16 Fußballprofi lernen, sind über 80 Prozent mit 18 arbeitslos und werden auch keine Anstellungen mehr in dem Beruf finden, den sie gelernt haben und müssen ganz was ganz Neues lernen. Und das ist auch etwas, was die PFA und die Premier League und der Englische Fußballverband erst jetzt begriffen haben, wie viel Hilfe und auch – da sind wir wieder beim Thema – auch psychische Unterstützung es dann für diese Jungs braucht, die ja einen Traum gelebt haben, der eigentlich die ganze Zeit bei den meisten schon eine Illusion war und die jetzt vor den Kopf gestoßen sind und ein ganz neues Leben beginnen müssen.
Was glauben Sie, woher müsste denn der Impuls in Deutschland kommen, um ein ähnliches Sicherheitsnetz aufzuziehen? Müsste das vom DFB kommen, von der DFL? Im besten Fall natürlich von beiden gemeinsam, klar.
Ich denke, in Deutschland müssten vor allem diese Tendenzen bekämpft werden, dass unser Fußballausbildungssystem immer englischer wird. Dass da immer höhere Gelder schon gezahlt werden an die Jungs im Sinne der Professionalität. Dass den Jungs unterschwellig immer mehr das Gefühl gegeben wird, die Schule ist nachrangig, sondern das müsste mehr darum gekämpft werden, was wir in Deutschland immer hatten. Also ein funktionierendes duales System, Fußballausbildung, Schulausbildung. Das war ja zum Beispiel die Nationalmannschaft. Ich meine, so um 2010 hatte eine höhere Abitursrate als der Gesellschaftsdurchschnitt in Deutschland. Das war eine fantastische Nationalmannschaft. Das zeigt, dass das eigentlich in den Jahren ab 2000, als die Nachwuchsleistungszentren erfunden wurden, bis 2012, 2013 hat das sehr gut funktioniert. Funktioniert immer noch für einen Teil der Fußballer. Aber die Tendenz ist schon in Deutschland auch zu erkennen, dass der Fußball alles andere an Bedeutung bei den Kindern schon im Alter von 15 und 16 immer mehr verdrängt. Das ist sicherlich nicht gesundheitsfördernd, auch für die Psyche.
Ich glaube auch, dass die Initiative, neben dem, dass man das strukturell von oben aufbaut, auch vor den Spielern vielleicht selber ausgehen sollte. Der VTV macht eine sehr gute Arbeit. Wenn sich mehr Spieler dort sammeln und ihre Interessen versuchen, dort zu vertreten, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man da entsprechende Initiativen starten könnte und dann vielleicht sekundär dann auch unterfüttert vielleicht mit etwas von dem Geld, was die Spieler sozusagen für andere erwirtschaften, dass man im Prinzip dann eine Struktur einfach stärkt. Ich glaube, dass der VTV da einen ganz guten Start schon macht. Ich kenne auch Herrn Baranowsky vom VTV. Die sind wirklich sehr engagiert und setzen sich dann doch zunehmend für die Interessen ein. Sie haben ja zum Beispiel aus dem Fußballcamp arbeitslose Fußballer. Es geht sicherlich auch so um Unterstützung bei Leuten, bei Spielern, die verletzt sind. Ich denke, das wäre vielleicht ein ganz guter Angriffspunkt oder ein guter Keimpunkt, aus dem raus sich sicherlich die Fußballer selber am besten auch ihre Interessenvertretung schaffen, in denen auch der Horizont über die Karriere und das Karriereende hinausgeht. Und vielleicht auch noch eine Struktur schafft, wie das dann nach dem Sport weitergehen kann.
Ja, da gibt es noch einiges zu tun. Ich habe noch mal kurz nachgeguckt. Also die PFA bekommt tatsächlich einen Großteil ihres Geldes aus den TV-Dis, der FA und der Premier League, und dann einen kleineren Teil noch durch Member-Subscriptions. Das sind dann eben auch Spieler, die sich engagieren mit dabei. So etwas Ähnliches könnte man doch auch in das.
Ja, und wenn man weiß, was dafür Summen bezahlt werden beim TV-Deal, dann ist die PFA eine ziemlich reiche Gesellschaft. In der Tat.
Ja, 24 bis 48 Millionen Pfund pro Jahr.
Richtig. Ja, die kaufen auch mal, die PFA kauft auch mal, steigert auch mal auf Kunst, bei Sosterbees auf Kunstversteigerung teure Bilder und legt ihr Geld dann in Kunst an und solche Sachen. Ich glaube, da ist die VDV in Deutschland noch deutlich davon entfernt, leider.
Ja gut, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob das das erstrebenswerte Ziel ist, in Kunst zu investieren, aber definitiv zeigt es, dass da andere Möglichkeiten bestehen als hier in Deutschland. Um diese Sendung hier so ein bisschen zum Abschluss zu bringen, würde ich Sie noch mal bitten, einmal Herr Dr. Henkel, wenn das jetzt betroffene Sportler hier vielleicht hören, und ich würde dann danach auch gerne noch mal auf Privatpersonen eingehen, nicht nur auf Sportler, aber was können denn Sportler tun, die das Gefühl haben, sie oder andere sind von Depressionen betroffen? An wen können sie sich, wohin können sie sich wenden?
Es gibt erstmal, wie gesagt, das Netzwerk, wo Sie Experten finden, wo Sie Zentren finden, die sportpsychiatrische Sprechstunden vorhalten. Auch nicht nur in Deutschland, wir haben inzwischen auch in Schweiz und in Österreich Kollegen. Und das wäre eine Möglichkeit. Es gibt daneben noch eine von der Robert-Enke-Stiftung initiierte Hotline, in der betroffene Sportler sich melden können und zunächst erstmal ein Beratungsgespräch, ein Informationsgespräch am Telefon haben können. Und wo ihnen diese Strukturen der Versorgung nahegelegt werden und wo sie schauen können, wo sie in ihrer Nähe zum Beispiel Hilfe bekommen können, was möglicherweise als nächster Ansprechpartner dort dient. Und diese Hotline ist dann fünf Tage die Woche für sechs Stunden geschaltet. Und sie ist letztlich für jeden erreichbar, entweder über die Enke-App selber oder aber halt telefonisch.
Ich werde Nummer und informative Links dazu alles auch noch in die Show Notes packen. Und wenn ich jetzt kein Sportler bin, wohin kann ich mich denn als Privatperson wenden?
Gut, diese Hotline selber wird auch von Nicht-Sportlern frequentiert. Aber natürlich, wenn jemand erkrankt ist und die Frage besteht, ob eine psychische Störung vorliegt, wären zum Beispiel der Hausarzt als früher Ansprechpartner. Oder aber halt dann, wenn die Sache klar ist in einer psychischen Erkrankung, natürlich ein niedergelassener Psychotherapeut, ein niedergelassener Psychiater oder Nervenarzt. Und es gibt natürlich je nach Krankheit Schwere, auch entsprechende stationäre Einrichtungen, Tageskliniken und da ist sicherlich der Zugang im Notfall natürlich auch jederzeit gegeben.
Ich habe bei meiner Recherche häufiger den WHO-5-Wohlfühltest oder Well-being-Index gesehen. Da soll man Fragen beantworten zum Gefühlszustand in den letzten zwei Wochen und dann gibt einem Punkteergebnis ein bisschen einen Hinweis zumindest in, ob man akut sich mal mit einem Fachmann zusammensetzen sollte. Würden Sie auch empfehlen, einen solchen Test zu wählen? Oder ist das schon so eine Sache, wo man sich dann vielleicht auch selbst belügt, wenn man ihn alleine am Monitor ausfüllt?
Ja, das ist ein grober Test mit, wie gesagt, ganz wenigen Fragen und fünf Fragen. Das kann mal ein Hinweis sein, aber das ersetzt natürlich keine Diagnose. Und auch wenn man da jetzt sozusagen nicht scoort, heißt das nicht unbedingt, dass man nicht vielleicht doch eine Depression haben könnte. Aber wichtig ist es einfach, wenn man merkt, dass etwas nicht stimmt, wenn man merkt, dass man dort wirklich krank ist, dann sollte man auch rasch die Hilfe suchen.
Und Herr Reng, was würden Sie sich wünschen? Sie sind ja auch ein Kuratorium der Robert Enke-Stiftung. Was sind so die nächsten Schritte in den nächsten Jahren, um auch im deutschen Profifußball das ganze Thema noch positiv voranzubringen?
Ich denke, das Wichtigste ist – und das ist ein vordellaufender Prozess und der wird wahrscheinlich ewig dauern – ist, dass Depressionen irgendwann eine selbstverständliche Krankheit sind. Selbstverständlich in dem Sinne nicht, dass man sagt, ah ja, du hast sie, ist ja normal und schüss und nicht behandelt. Sondern selbstverständlich in dem Sinne, dass wenn man gehört, wenn jemand im Fußballverein oder auch sonst in der Familie die Diagnose hört von einem Freund, von einer Tochter, von einem Sohn, er leidet unter Depression, dass dann diese Personen um ihn herum damit genauso viel anfangen können, wie mit Kreuzbandriss und Patella absehenden Anriss und Krippe. Also das ist einfach ein Grundwissen. Sicher nicht ein detailliertes medizinisches Wissen, aber ein Grundwissen, was sind Depressionen, welche Schritte muss ich einleiten bei der Behandlung, was sind Depressionen nicht, wie kann man nach der Depression weiterleben, dass dieses Wissen sich einfach weiterverbreitet und irgendwann dann die Leute damit so selbstverständlich umgehen, wie mit Patella-Sehnen anrissen und Kreuzbandrissen.
Ja, das ist ja das eigentlich Bizarre, dass auch ich, das gebe ich offen zu, mehr über Schambeinentzündungen wusste, weil das Ayn Robben mal so lange hatte, als über Depressionen. Aber wie man auch an mir sieht, kann man an seinem Wissen arbeiten und sich dann eine Kompetenz aufbauen. Und das mit der Schambeinentzündung wäre eigentlich viel weniger wichtig, ehrlich gesagt, für meinen Alltag, als das, was ich mir jetzt so alles angelesen habe zu diesem Thema.
Ja, also ich denke auch, weil Sie haben am Anfang ja auch gesagt, ein nicht so leichtes Thema. Ich glaube, wenn man das Wissen hat, die Leute haben ja vor allem, oder wir Menschen haben vor allem vor etwas Angst, über das wir nichts wissen. Und wenn man das Wissen hat, dann ist die Krankheit sicherlich nicht leichter zu vertragen, aber es fällt einfach leichter, damit umzugehen. Und dann ist es auch nicht mehr so schwer. Diese Schwere geben wir der Krankheit ja auch davon, weil wir vorher erstarren und davor nichts wissen wollen.
Ja, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Und natürlich auch, weil die Fälle, mit denen man sich beschäftigt, immer so extrem sind. Also ich habe jetzt, wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, alle Sportlerbiografien von deutschen Sportlern gelesen. Vornehmlich Fußballern, die da betroffen waren. Das sind dann natürlich auch mal ganz extreme Schilderungen. Und das ist mir dann selber irgendwann nahe gegangen. Und da tat jetzt auch mir diese Sendung sehr gut, das Ganze mal wieder runter zu kochen auf einem normalen Maß und klarzumachen, das sind die Extremschilderungen. Und es gibt aber noch ganz, ganz viele andere Ausprägungsformen.
Ich glaube, wenn Sie eine Sendung machen würden mit zwei 44-jährigen Fußballern und die würden völlig authentisch, ohne Rücksicht Ihnen schildern, wie es Ihnen körperlich geht, das wäre nach einer 20-jährigen Karriere, ich glaube, das wäre wirklich viel, viel erschreckender. Wenn die Ihnen dann alles aufzählen würden, dann würden sie auch nicht mit zwei Stunden in Sendezeit hinkommen. Also wenn die aufzählen würden, was sie alles erlitten haben, hier Karriere von Kapselriss bis abgerissenes Ohr und die Nase gebrochen beim Ellbogencheck und wie es Ihnen jetzt geht. Also die körperlichen Schicksale von Fußballern sind deutlich weit verbreiteter und schwerwirkender, werden aber banalisiert im Fußball.
Ich glaube, wir müssen uns klar machen, dass Leid auch immer individuell ist und es gar keinen Sinn macht zu vergleichen, dass was der eine als nicht so schlimm empfindet, kann für den anderen sehr unangenehm sein. Zum Beispiel Schmerzwahrnehmung oder wie gesagt aber auch Depressivität. Ich glaube, man erfährt ja von den Betroffenen selber, wie sehr ihnen etwas beeinträchtigt, wie sehr darunter leidet. Das sollte man auch wahrnehmen und nicht relativieren oder vergleichen. Ich glaube, was die Emotionen, wie jemand damit umgeht, mit Symptomen, die nicht funktionieren, mit ausgeschlossen sein, das kann sozusagen großes Leid verursachen und ist einfach nicht skalierbar, sondern individuell manchmal sehr bedeutend.
Ja, völlig richtig. Meine Herren, vielen herzlichen Dank für die Zeit. Das waren zum einen Dr. Karsten Henkel, Oberarzt an der Uniklinik Aachen und Facharzt für Psychiatrie und Psychotherapie. Er hat unter anderem die sportpsychiatrische Sprechstunde gemacht. Jetzt wissen wir alle, was das eigentlich ist. Vielen Dank, Herr Dr. Henkel, für Ihre Zeit.
Danke für die Möglichkeit, auch sozusagen etwas über die Depression weiterzugeben und ein bisschen mehr Bewusstsein und Sensibilität zu schaffen.
Ich hoffe, es ist auf fruchtbaren Boden bei meinen Hörern und Hörern gefallen. Ich gehe aber fast davon aus. Und ebenso großer Dank. Vielen Dank an Ronald Reng, der unter anderem das Buch zu Robert Enke geschrieben hat, ganz viele andere tolle Fußballbücher auch. Herr Reng, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank für die Zeit, die Sie sich genommen haben. Und damit dann auch Dank an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das bis hierhin gehört haben und die vielleicht sogar den Rasenfunk unterstützen. Der Rasenfunk ist werbefrei, sponsorenfrei. Und irgendwann möchte ich auch mal meinen Gästen, gerade wenn ich so tolle Gäste habe wie in dieser Sendung, ein Honorar zahlen können. Dazu braucht es noch ein bisschen mehr finanzielle Unterstützung von euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Alle Informationen findet ihr dazu auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn diese Folge hier Verbreitung findet und vielleicht auch dem einen oder anderen dann ja vielleicht auch selbst weiterhilft. Das würde mich sehr freuen. In diesem Sinne vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und dann hören wir uns wieder in einem der nächsten Tribünengespräche oder einer der nächsten Schlusskonferenzen. Kurzpässe gibt es auch noch. Liebe Hörer, macht's gut, bis bald, tschüss! Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.